Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Wahrscheinlich die schlechteste Uhrzeit zu streamen in der ganzen Woche.
Montag 12.50 Uhr.
Beste Uhrzeit?
Ja, wenn man nicht arbeiten muss oder kein Mittagessen isst, dann wahrscheinlich schon, ja.
Aber für die meisten eher nicht.
Ich mach mal kurz meine 4M an.
Weil das ja das ist, was wir heute wahrscheinlich ablösen können.
Ich lass die 4M einfach mal aus. Brauchen wir ja nicht.
Ich hab mir nämlich eine Capture Card bestellt.
Ich hab mir hier bei
eine Elgato 4K Pro bestellt.
Übrigens, Moment. Ich muss mal kurz
Tastatur raus, Tastatur rein.
Gachi Roll.
Was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder?
Meine Güte, ey.
Das Logi...
Keine Ahnung, früher, ne?
Früher war, ich weiß, ob er Max erzählt vom Krieg, aber früher war die Logitech-Software irgendwas.
Das hast du installiert und dann war das halt da und hat funktioniert.
Und jetzt spackt das die ganze Zeit rum mit irgendwas.
So, jetzt ist die Farbe von meiner RGB-Beleuchtung richtig.
Genau, ich habe mir so ein Ding hier bestellt.
Und das ist tatsächlich, ich hätte es ja nicht für möglich gehalten, dass das nochmal passiert.
Das ist mein letzter freier PCI Express Slot gewesen.
Guck mal hier.
Äh, Geizhals.
Ist das...
So, hier, guck mal.
Das Mainboard, hier, das da, das hat drei PCI Express Slots.
Moin, Max.
Drei PCI...
Hier ist die Grafikkarte drin.
Die Grafikkarte braucht gefühlt den kompletten Platz hier.
Hier unten ist die 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte drin.
und hier ist jetzt die capture card drinne also ich habe wirklich das hätte ich nicht für möglichkeit
dass ich das noch mal sehe ein komplett voll bestücktes mainboard pc express ich glaube das
einzige was ich noch frei habe auf dem mainboard sind der großteil der sata anschlüsse und ich
glaube eine ssd ist hier noch frei irgendwo in der mitte dies belegt dies belegt diese ein also
Also eines hier glaube ich noch frei drunter.
M.2 SSDs.
Hier auch.
Hier ist der M.2 SSD drunter.
Und hier sind glaube ich, bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher, ob zwei oder drei.
Ich glaube drei.
Und davon sind nur zwei belegt bei mir.
Sieht man ja auch hier irgendwo.
Ja, drei. Drei Stück sind da drunter.
Und das ist die hier, die direkt an dem PCI Express von der CPU dran hängt.
Was potenziell die schnellste ist.
Aber ganz im Ernst, das macht es jetzt auch nicht wirklich fett, der Unterschied.
Ja.
Genau, und hier ist jetzt die Elgato Capture Card drin.
Eine 4K Pro von Elgato.
Wie sprechen das eigentlich die coolen Leute aus, Elgato?
Wie spreche ich, Eljado oder?
Es gibt ja Leute, die müssen alles cool betonen.
Ich sage Elgato.
Elgato sagen die, glaube ich, die Amis. Elgato.
Ja.
Genau, das Teil hier.
Und was ich mir damit erhoffe ist, weil angeblich geht das ja, es gibt hier Elgato 4K Matrix, Elgato Pro Supported Resolutions, guck mal hier, angeblich kann man da, wenn man mit 1080p 240Hz,
kann man
1080p
240 Hertz capturen.
Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren, ja.
Weil das ist das Setup, wie ich
den Linux-Mini-PC laufen lassen will.
Darkseid,
danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, 240 Hertz, dass das alles richtig schön
lagfrei ist und der Output kommt dann
einfach hier Fullscreen in einem zweiten
OBS auf dem zweiten Monitor. Fertig.
So,
soweit die
die die Theorie.
Ich mach mal kurz hier das
OBS einfach.
Ja.
Das ist hier, das ist nämlich nicht wirklich OBS,
sondern das wird dann quasi, ähm...
Hab ich eben verklickt oder hat das
einfach nicht funktioniert? Ja, das wird der Output
von der Linux VM werden hier dann.
Die Video Capture, die war... Ach, guck mal!
Der müsste die zumindest... Ja, okay, er erkennt
die auch schon. Guck hier.
4k pro und da kann man hier sagen custom resolution
1080 240 guck da
Dass das brauche ich dann ich kann es ich kann es ja eigentlich schon mal so einstellen dass es passt
Notation data brauche nicht hardware encoding disable buffering ganz wichtig und sound ausgabe
so hier kann ich mich muten das heißt aber ihr hört mich immer noch weil das ja hier drüber geht
und desktop kann ich auch muten weil man weiß ja nie so wobei desktop muss wahrscheinlich anlassen
und da kann man dann mal gucken ob ich 1000 hp 240 hertz schrieben soll kann was wir aber vorher
noch machen müssen, ganz essentiell
wichtig, guck mal hier, hallo Leute,
Winkchamp,
ähm,
was wir vorher noch machen müssen ist,
ich muss noch eine SSD einbauen,
in die Kiste, also ich hab hier,
warte mal, warte mal,
ich switche mal kurz um,
und hol jetzt mal den Mini-PC,
den habt ihr ja glaube ich schon mal,
habt ihr den überhaupt schon mal gesehen?
Also benutzt haben wir den im Stream schon mal,
warte mal, ich mach mal kurz hier den ganzen Krempel raus,
Netzwerkkarte raus,
hdmi kabel raus und strom war aber raus
guck hier so schaut er aus der mini pc nicht ganz schön viel krebs rum aber so
ist es halt.
Also richtig kleines
kleines
Teil. Hier oben
passiv.
Ich muss mir mal kurz die Vorschau
im Großbildschirm an.
Ne, wirklich basteln wird's nicht.
Gebastelt wird ja nicht großartig.
Was ist denn das da unten eigentlich? Guck mal hier.
Das hat hier so ein
so ein
Stück Gummi.
Ach, das ist, dass man den Boden abheben kann, einfacher wahrscheinlich, hä?
Stimmt, da unten macht man ja auch auf.
Ich hatte das Ding schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr offen.
Letztes Mal zum, zum, zum RAM ausbauen.
Ja, also das ist ein, das sieht man ja auch, die Farbe ist jetzt nicht so schön.
Ich weiß nicht, das kommt im Stream gar nicht so richtig raus, oder?
Chat, wie würdet ihr die Farbe von dem Ding sehen?
Was hat das Ding für eine Farbe aus eurer Sicht?
Das ist schwierig im Stream zu erkennen, weil man immer nicht so genau weiß, ja, wie, welche Farbe.
Was sagt ihr, hat das Ding für eine Farbe?
Dunkelgrün? Ja, richtig.
Ich finde, es könnte auch fast ein bisschen, es könnte auch fast schwarz sein im Stream, wenn man sich das so anguckt.
Ja, aber es ist dunkelgrün.
Ja, ist es. Dunkelgrün.
Man sieht es ein bisschen im Vergleich hier zu dem blauen Untergrund.
Ja, ist dunkelgrün, genau.
Ja, also die schönste Farbe ist es jetzt nicht, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Da habe ich schon schönere Hardware gesehen.
Aber an sich ist das Ding echt okay.
Das ist auch schon ein bisschen älter, den gibt es mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
Den habe ich jetzt hier über ein Jahr oder so rumliegen gehabt bei mir.
Aber insgesamt ist das Ding trotzdem gut.
Hat fast, fast exakt die gleiche Rechenleistung und GPU-Leistung
wie mein nass in meinem nass ist ein reisen 7 255 drin mit einer radio und 780m und hier ist
ein reisen bohr fragt mich nicht 7800 hx oder irgendwie sowas drin aber auch mit einer 780m
also die gleiche gpu wie immer im nass und hat auch acht kerne 16 threads also im prinzip mehr
oder weniger eins zu eins die gleiche leistung wie offen das aber ist ja auch wurscht zumindest
ist, was ich mir jetzt vorgestellt
habe, ist, haben sie letztens auch schon mal kurz
ausprobiert, äh, hier
kommt ein Linux drauf,
also, warum auch immer ich jetzt auf den
Passivkühler zeige, also hier, hier, da,
da, hier, auf die Kühlrippe
kommt das Linux drauf,
da kommt ein Linux drauf
mit, also ich hab ja schon ein Linux drauf
installiert, aber ich will das so machen,
ich hab hier noch eine alte,
guck mal hier Leute, noch eine alte
970 Evo,
die ist
locker fünf Jahre alt, oder? Steht hier irgendwo?
Oder noch älter?
Guck mal, sieht man hier irgendwo ein Datum drauf?
Chatge, wartet mal, wir machen das mal kurz.
Bisschen mal, bisschen die
Zoom-Using.
Da steht irgendwo was
drauf, oder? Zeig mal.
2019, Alter!
Die SSD ist einfach mal sieben Jahre alt.
Seht ihr das da oben?
2019 steht da drauf.
Aber ich meine,
ist ja egal, die tut ja immer noch.
Warum auch nicht?
So.
Genau, die bauen wir da jetzt ein,
dann ist der Linus drauf und dann hoffe ich,
dann hoffe ich, dass das funktioniert,
dass ich 1080p 240Hz
capturen kann und das dann auf dem zweiten Desktop
easy,
lagfrei
läuft weil dann wird das hier die ablöse von meiner vm dann ist gibt es kein
teiling window manager mehr dann gibt es kde plasma
wie lange hält noch mal eine ssd zehn jahre im durchschnitt die ssd hält je
nachdem wie viel du drauf schreibst du kannst eine ssd wenn du findest also
konsumers ssd wenn du 24 7 drauf schreibst wahrscheinlich ein paar
monaten easy kaputt machen das kann aber auch jahre halten und wir können ja
nachher erinnert mich mal dran wir gucken mal nachher smart wie viel von
der ssd hier benutzt ist die hatte ich jetzt schon in zwei rechnergenerationen
drin da muss ein bisschen wird wahrscheinlich was drauf geschrieben
worden sein schon aber letztendlich dürfte das war gehe ich mal von aus es
bestimmt immer noch bei 90 prozent haltbarkeit also der kram das war mal
ganz im ernst du schreibst ja da nicht viel drauf was
schreibst was benutzt im normalen desktop betrieb da schreibt da glitzert
man ab und zu mal ein game aber jetzt zu 99 prozent der zeit eitel der kram
darum und es passiert nichts ja windows schreibt die ein oder andere
loks vielleicht mal aber es ist das ist nicht viel jetzt erst mal kurz gucken
wie man das Ding aufkriegt.
Wie kriegt man das Ding auf?
Wahrscheinlich hier an den Schrauben da, oder?
Moment, ich muss...
Na, jetzt muss ich das hier mal so blöd drauflegen.
Wobei, dann sieht man auch was, wenn das ein bisschen
schepp ist. Ich gucke mal,
ob das der richtige...
Der richtige ist nicht
der richtige Schraubchamp. Moment, ich brauche
den richtigen Schraubchamp dafür.
War der da vielleicht?
Ne, der ist es auch nicht.
Was sind das wieder für Kackschrauben?
der hier vielleicht treff nicht chat
der geht okay der ist den braun wenn du zelt nutzt macht easy kaputt ja wie gesagt wenn
es darauf anlegt kriegst du die ssd auch locker kaputt ja wenn wir dem free nas forum glaubt was
nicht mehr FreeNAS Forum heißt,
dann darfst du ja ZFS auf gar
keinen Fall auf Consumer SSDs.
Der wird dann
so getan, als ist
ein paar 100 KB Lock aufkommen
am Tag, der Tod für die Consumer
SSD. Nach zwei Jahren.
Weißt du, paar 100 KB
Locks am Tag so.
Da wird teilweise ein Blödsinn geschrieben.
Genauso wie dieses ganze Zeug mit
ZFS kannst du dir
ohne ECC-Rahmen auch gleich sparen
und so ein Bullshit.
Es wird nur noch getoppt vom Mikrocontroller-Forum.
Also die Schrauben, das ist gar nicht so einfach zu erwischen.
So, machen wir hier mal raus.
Schmeißen wir mal hier in die Ecke.
Schreiker, ey, ohne Mist.
Ich hatte glaube ich auch schon, also ich habe jetzt hier in meinem, also daheim wohlgemerkt, ja, hier in meinem Unraid-Server habe ich jetzt seit, wie lange gibt es den, 5 Jahre oder so, ganz normale Samsung-Konsume-SSDs und die haben wahrscheinlich immer noch 98% Haltbarkeit.
Ja, das ist, weil die immer so ein Mist im Forum schreiben, ne?
Mundterror.
ZFS ist auch nicht schlechter
wie andere Filesysteme
ohne ECC-RAM.
Man gewinnt ja trotzdem immer noch viel, ja.
Also, diese ganze Check-Sum-Geschichten,
die das macht, um zu gucken,
okay, was weiß ich, die
Zelle von der SSD verliert langsam
zu viel haltbarkeit und die bits stimmen nicht mehr und das erkennt das ja immer noch das war
das ding erst mal auf und man guckt mal wie man ordentlichen ssd reinkriegt wenn ich glück habe
ja dann ist die der ssd slot oben und ich krieg das easy raus wenn ich muss man das halbe ding
zerlegen es ist ja schon eine ssd drin also aktuell ist hier glaube ich da ein oder zwei
terabyte ssd die drinnen mit der das ausgeliefert wurde und jetzt muss er noch
eine zweite rein für die zweite linux installation weil ich werde das so
machen ich werde das natürlich auch privat benutzen also was privat wie ich
bin sicher kein krasses business
also ich benutze das einmal für mich oft stream und stream und ich baue einfach
für jedes verwendungszweck der ssd eigentlich dass man irgendwie aus
versehen Sachen liegt oder sowas.
Äh, ups.
Und ich will, dass die Platten auch gar nichts
miteinander zu tun haben. Ich habe mir schon überlegt,
vielleicht soll ich einfach einen zweiten User anlegen
und dann mich im Stream mit einloggen.
Ja, das könnte man machen, aber ganz ehrlich,
mir ist es fast lieber, es ist eine zweite Platte, da kommt man
sich da auch gar nicht in die Quere.
Man wählt einfach beim Booten kurz aus, was man
starten will und gut ist, Tastatur muss
ich eh anschließen, um
das
Gutfallsystem zu entsperren.
Also insofern, easy.
F-Programmer sagt, ich habe den Stream vom Samstag nachgehört.
Oh, da hast du aber einiges zu tun, da ging noch siebeneinhalb Stunden.
Ich habe kürzlich eine unverpackt...
Was? Moment.
Unverpackt laden...
Ein was für ein Ding?
Unverpackt laden?
Was ist das denn?
Ach, du meinst...
Ach so.
Du meinst, wo ich mich aufgeregt habe,
dass manche keine keine kartenzahlung akzeptieren was apple pay 1,6 prozent
Was ist denn ein NVMe-TCP-Drive?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das hat nichts mit Netzwerk-TCP zu tun, oder?
So, jetzt können wir diesen Nippel da unten auch gebrauchen, weil das kann man hier aufziehen.
Guck mal, easy.
Die SSD kommt direkt hier rein.
Das hat sich ja schnell erledigt.
Was ist denn das da eigentlich, Chat?
Seht ihr das?
Das ist gar nichts, oder?
Ich habe gedacht, vielleicht konnte man...
Irgendwie habe ich gerade gedacht...
Guck mal, HDD-Disk.
Heißt das, man kann hier eine...
Man kann hier irgendwie eine SATA oder so?
Nee.
Das ist einfach Blödsinn, was da steht.
Von wegen HDD-Disk.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Wartet mal.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Da ist kein SATA-Anschluss.
Ich meine, passen
würde hier eine SATA?
Passen würde hier eigentlich eine SATA-Disk rein?
Nicht wegen dem Knubbel,
aber es ist halt kein SATA-Anschluss da.
Das ist ein ganz normaler
M2 NVMe-Stecker.
Also keine Ahnung, wie hier eine
HDD-Disk rein soll.
Was auch immer.
So, dann
machen wir den hier mal raus.
Und jetzt machen wir die SSD rein.
Okay.
es ist die nacht
das ganze ding wieder zu
ja ich finde auch die auskärmung aber da ist kein anschluss für sata vielleicht gibt es da
Vielleicht gibt es noch eine andere Version, wo man
eine SATA-Disk reinmachen kann.
Das wäre ja vielleicht
noch möglich.
Du hast den RAM noch
geklaut?
Äh, nee.
Ich hab das so gemacht.
Ich hab die 32 GB hier rausgemacht.
Die sind hier unten drunter.
und hab 8 Gig von meinem RAM eingebaut.
Äh, 8 Gig RAM
von meinem NAS eingebaut. Also ich hab quasi
32 Gig hier raus ins NAS eingebaut
und 8 Gig vom NAS
da rein. Also das sind aktuell nur 8 Gig,
aber das sollte ja erst nochmal reichen.
Es sei denn, ich will wieder 3 Jetplane
IDEs aufmachen, dann klappt das nicht.
Die Dinger fressen ja RAM wie sonst was.
Wackelt ein bisschen.
Warte mal, gucken wir mal, ob das...
Ist aber eigentlich fest.
naja dann wackelt die SSD halt ein bisschen, immerhin juckt es. So guck mal man hat hier sogar ein
Heatpad drauf, man sollte ja eigentlich nicht so dran rumfummeln ja, dass das
ganze nicht so warm wird. Schauen wir mal. Zack.
Machen wir dicht. Dann installieren wir uns mal Linux drauf und gucken ob das ganze mit der
Capture-Karte 240 Hz funktioniert. Ich habe übrigens auch den Fehler gefunden
mit der Maus-Sharing-Software.
Das kann ich euch auch gleich zeigen.
Also mein Ziel ist ja, dass ich auf dem zweiten Desktop
die Linux-Kiste
hier angezeigt bekommen kann.
Möglichst lagfrei Tastatur und Maus
sharen kann. Und dass ich im Endeffekt
Linux und Windows weiterhin parallel benutzen kann.
Nur, dass ich eine echte Linux-Kiste drunter habe
und nicht mehr meine VM.
Die Schraube geht nicht mehr rein.
Auch geil.
Das ist irgendwie broken.
Okay.
Die scheint ausgeleiert zu sein.
Nice, die Schraube ist im Arsch.
Exzellente China-Chinesen-Qualität.
Gucken wir mal, dass wir erstmal irgendwie über Kreuz was reinmachen.
Ja, das geht noch.
Dann muss das jetzt mit drei Schrauben auskommen.
So.
Da sind wir wieder
Heißglä, Quatsch, drei Schrauben tun
So, ich probiere die, aber warte mal
Jetzt komme ich besser dran, da muss es ja nicht in der Kamera sein
Gucke mal
Vielleicht kriege ich hier doch noch was rein
Ne, die greift nicht mehr, die Schraube
Kannst du knicken, die ist
Das ist broken
Naja, dann
Haben wir halt nur drei Schrauben drinnen
Gut, dann schließen wir das jetzt mal an
Und schauen wir gleich mal
Ob das funzt
Mit der Elgato Capture Card
Schauen wir mal hier, machen wir mal hier auf
Linux VM
Capture Card
4K Pro, 1920x1080
20 FPS
So, jetzt muss ich das nochmal anschließen
Hier, das seht ihr jetzt nicht
erstmal Strom dran machen
ähm
Netzwerkkabel dran machen
HDMI Output
dran machen, so
dann Tastatur einmal
dran, weil wir haben ja noch kein Tastatursharing
am Start
Tastatur dran
jetzt
schalten wir ein, ich hoffe
ich bin schnell genug und kann das BIOS aufmachen
und dann die passende
SSD auswählen
Schauen wir mal
Okay, funktioniert
Chat, ich mach mal Fullscreen
Das kann ich hier
Inzwischen umschalten
So, also, was haben wir denn hier
Wo wählt man aus, was man booten will
Man haben hier
NVMe-Lima, okay, das ist das schon installierte
Das ist das schon installierte
Danach kommt Boot-Option
PXE, ja, das ist das, was ich
im Endeffekt jetzt auch machen will.
Heute CacheUS Desktop Gaming
Setup, finally. Ja.
Kann man jetzt
hier drinnen nicht sagen, ich will den da
booten?
Gibt es nicht so Boot Override
oder sowas, dass ich quasi nur
einmal jetzt PXE boote?
Habt ihr sowas
gesehen?
Ach hier, Boot Override.
Okay
Jetzt kommt gleich wieder KI-Katzen
Bild
Ich hoffe, ich habe meinen PXE nicht kaputt gemacht
Ich habe nämlich gestern noch ein bisschen dran rumgefummelt
So, dass ich jetzt auch ordentlich
4M spooten kann
Äh, okay
Da haben wir es, also CacheUS
KI-Katze
Heute Morgen stand bei mir eine Katze im Garten
Da bin ich hin
Da wollte die erst abhauen
Aber ich hab ja natürlich
Ich weiß ja schon, worauf die stehen
Ich hab so eine Dose Knusper-Ecken mitgenommen
Und bin dann
In geduckter Haltung
Durch den Hof gelaufen
Und hab da gemacht
Und hab geraschelt
Mit dem Zeug
und dann ist sie nicht abgehauen, ist hergekommen.
Ne, die gehört ja jemand.
So dick wie die war, die gehört jemand.
Konntest du das Problem lösen, dass der Mauszeiger beim Umschalten doppelt ist?
Ja.
Ohne eigenes Programm für Mauszeiger-Hiden.
Wie CacheUS.
Ich hoffe, man kann CacheUS auch mit Tastatur-Only installieren,
weil ich habe jetzt keinen Bock, hier umzustöpseln.
stöpseln wobei machen wir einfach komme ich stöpsel einfach hier die andere die
andere maus dran und gut ist hat man sagt wenn die andere maus noch dran
muss ich nur gucken dass nicht durcheinander kommen welche maus welche
tastatur hier gerade was schneestelle schnee ist dieses ist für dieses jahr
hoffentlich vorbei so schau mal ob das jetzt funktioniert sieht schon mal ganz
gut aus jetzt schauen wir mal wie gut das cash ios setup damit zurecht kommt
wenn man zwei
SSDs hat,
wo auf beiden CacheOS,
quasi auf einer schon CacheOS drauf installiert ist,
ob man das gescheit auswählen kann.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Das sollte ja eigentlich
basic sein, dass man auswählen kann,
auf welche Platte es installiert wird.
Chat.
Wieso CacheOS?
Weil aktueller Hype CacheOS ist.
Äh.
Hallo?
Chat?
Ah, jetzt.
Alter, was ist das für eine Auflösung, man?
WTF, was ist das für eine Auflösung?
Das ist ja mini.
Und lädt das heute auch nochmal vielleicht so?
So zur Abwechslung?
Laden?
Cache-Stells?
Ja, 4K-Capture-Card.
Der wählt standardmäßig anscheinend 4K jetzt aus als Auflösung.
Aber soll mir ja auch recht sein, ist ja okay.
Aber kann das sein, dass
CacheOS, das aktuelle CacheOS
ISO irgendwie kaputt ist?
Weil ich hab das neuste
CacheOS ISO gestern runtergeladen
und in mein PXE gepackt.
Ist das
broken?
Das würde mich
jetzt ja ein wenig abfacken.
Wenn das broken ist.
Chat meint er, der macht noch was?
Oder ist er komplett...
Oh, jetzt ist die Maus sogar gefreest, Leute.
Leute, ich fürchte, das lädt nicht mehr.
Control-Alt-Alt.
Du meinst, die Konsole wechseln?
Ja, das kann man doch machen.
Geht nicht.
man kann nicht mal mehr die konsole switchen oder moment moment moment moment
moment jetzt ist die große preisfrage
warum löscht er das wieder aha das sind wir cash us
wo ist das laggy as fuck was ist denn da los
sonst können wir h top machen oder top gucken was er gerade was er da eigentlich
gerade treibt der volle cpu auslastung plasma shell so der stadt der startet noch oder
schaltet wiederum
umschaltchamp da sind wir alter das hat aber lange gedauert ich glaube da hat probleme mit
mit 4k. Leute, ich glaube,
der hat echt Probleme, weil es 4k
ist. Auf der anderen Seite,
seriously, der sollte
eigentlich keine Probleme haben
mit 4k.
Oh, juckt
das.
Fresh install.
Da ist noch gar nichts installiert. Das ist das
Live-System.
sogar die maus hängt richtig hart
nice nice archlinux experience
ich kann nicht mal das fenster bewegen
Ich kann nicht mal was klicken
Ich kann es vergessen
PXE, ja
Aber
Ich hab das ja gestern
Vorgestern, irgendwann haben wir das ja schon mal PXE geboot
Überhaupt kein Problem, ging
Oh, oh, oh
Ich glaube, der hat Probleme mit 4K.
Irgendwie ist das so meine...
Meine Vermutung,
dass der Probleme mit 4K hat.
Oh, oh, oh, Leute.
Oh, es moved.
Huge.
Jetzt moved es nicht mehr.
Der hat Probleme mit 4K.
Guck mal, jetzt ist es komplett gefreezed wieder.
Scheiße.
Tja, gut.
Ich würde dir gerne...
Wie können wir CacheOS booten?
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Ähm, wartet mal.
Tastatur wieder umstecken.
CacheOS
Live
Resolution
Kann man das ändern?
Ich meine, hier habe ich dem ja schon gesagt.
An die Maus geht.
Das lädt nicht.
Ich kann es vergessen.
Hier habe ich dem ja schon gesagt.
Ach, guck mal.
Jetzt hat er auf einmal nur noch 1000.
Nur noch 120 FPS.
Ey, soll mir auch recht sein.
Hauptsache, der macht jetzt was.
Macht er aber nicht.
Dann, ich habe eine Idee.
Warte mal.
Ich deaktiviere mal kurz meine Capture Card.
Und dann activate ich die wieder
Vielleicht bringt das irgendwas
Ey, bringt nix
Ja gut, äh
Okay, ich hab ne Idee
Freifahrt
Freifahrt-Time
Oh, was ist jetzt hier?
Guck mal da, Leute, habt ihr das gesehen?
Guck mal da
Display-Configuration
drei Stunden später.
Ne, das liegt, das liegt.
Ich könnte meine,
ich könnte die KVM dran machen.
KVM dran.
Und wir installieren mit KVM.
Und wenn es dann installiert ist,
geht es vielleicht besser.
Aber das ist ja Schrott.
Okay, komm. Ich starte
den Eimer noch neu.
Schauen wir mal.
Weil das ist echt nicht normal.
Wir gucken noch mal was.
Meint ihr, der hat zu wenig
meint, oh, oh, fuck.
Sekunde.
Falsch Knopf.
Äh.
Meint ihr, der hat zu wenig
Run für das
Cache, für das Cache-Live-System?
Aber ich meine, er hat 8 GB
und auf dem anderen funzt es ohne Probleme.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Wir können aber mal kurz was gucken,
ob man hier
Grafikkarte.
Leute, ich stelle die Grafikkarte jetzt einfach
runter um 128 MB. So, easy.
Und danach stelle ich sie wieder hoch,
nachdem ich sie installiert habe.
Haben wir noch
ein halbes Gig mehr RAM jetzt?
Jetzt ist easy. Halbes Gig mehr RAM.
Kein Problem mehr.
Wenn nicht, machen wir das Ganze
mit der KVM. Ist auch okay.
Äh, hallo?
Hallo? Starten, please?
Starte das verdammte Spiel!
Der Rammpreis geht angeblich wieder runter.
Wie kommst du, also wer sagt das und wie kommst du da drauf?
Okay, Cashy.
Jetzt aber.
Ich hoffe, dass das jetzt funktioniert.
Der hat vielleicht Probleme mit dem RAM,
weil er denkt, er muss 4K-Auflösung machen.
kann man nämlich irgendwie sagen dass man da gab es doch eine setting für die capture
cards dass man den sagen konnte lasst mal nicht nicht 4k nur 1080p aber schauen ob es jetzt geht
jetzt hat er immer eine zeit ein halbes gig mehr haben jetzt soll es funktionieren wenn ich kvm
anschließen.
Muss mal was trinken.
Ich hab ganz trockenen Hals.
So, Chat, meint ihr, es geht jetzt?
Ich hab ja das blöde Gefühl, irgendwie
boote das über PXE nicht richtig.
Vielleicht sind 8 GB einfach
zu wenig.
Äh
Äh, der ist gefreest
Jetzt hat er komplett gefreest
Das funktioniert ja richtig gut
Excellent
Das ist ja
Very pock
Okay, ein Ding
Ein Ding probiere ich jetzt noch, Chat
Ein Ding probiere ich noch
Auf die Gefahr hin, dass der vielleicht zu wenig
Dass der vielleicht zu wenig
Grafikrahmen hatte
Für 4K
Wie viel
VRAM braucht man für 4K?
Ich meine, da ist ja nichts 3D
Ich gebe dem jetzt nochmal ein bisschen mehr RAM
Für die Grafikkarte
So, und wenn nicht, dann installieren wir mit KVM.
So, Moment, wo musste ich hin?
AMD CBS, NBIOI.
Die Dinger sind immer so krass kryptisch benannt.
GFX Configuration.
Okay, 2 GB.
1 GB.
2 GB, komm, 2 GB.
Dann habe ich noch 6 GB frei für CacheOS.
Gucken, ob das reicht, ey.
Auto.
Weiß ich nicht.
Was macht Auto?
Woher denn das mal mit 2G?
Auto können wir auch noch mal probieren.
so und jetzt sagen wir hier nochmal gut ich sehe was passiert wohl immer 16 gig
bei 8 g gramm einstellt so gute frage schwarzes loch im mini pc legt bestimmt
an der fehlen vier schrauben leute leute ich weiß woran es liegt sind bestimmt
mikro risse im mainboard oder was denkt ihr wie auf einem anderen pc mikro risse
im Mainboard.
Ja, so ein zweiter RAM-Riegel
wäre nicht verkehrt. Ganz ehrlich,
8 GB RAM sind doch ein bisschen
wenig.
So ein zweiter RAM-Riegel
Nochmal 8 Gig, was kosten 8 Gig DDR5 aktuell?
Sag mal
Jetzt reicht der RAM nicht
Jetzt bin ich out of memory
For fuck's sake, Alter
Reboot
8 Gig
Leute, schreibt nicht irgendeinen Blödsinn
Das kostet keine 500 Euro
Oder keine 600 Euro
Oder auch keine 420 Euro
8 Gig dürfte doch gar nicht
Ist nicht in einem deiner Nass noch 8 Gig
Doch, aber eins davon will ich ja wieder
Zurückschicken, ich kann denen ja schlecht die 8 Gig
Klauen, aus dem Nass
Und das Nass dann leer zurückschicken
Und wollen, dass die mir das Geld erstatten
Wobei können, können man das wahrscheinlich schon
Wahrscheinlich wird es keiner kontrollieren
Was? Ich habe 3 Nasses
Eins, eins ist komplett
original verpackt das hat acht gig noch drin das andere ukraine ist leer die 8
gigs sind hier in dem mini pc und das n5 luft das hat die 32 gig trainer die
frühen mini pc drin waren auto machen wir jetzt wenn es jetzt nicht geht
dann machen wir das anders
Ich mache heute gar kein Homeoffice.
Sinnlose Copypasta.
Laptop von der Arbeit.
Man sich soll da den RAM ausbauen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das...
Also überhaupt. Also ich will nicht
und ich glaube nicht, dass es möglich wäre.
SO Dim ab 97 Euro.
Okay, das geht doch eigentlich, oder?
Ich meine, es ist zwar abfuck, dass es so teuer ist.
Vor einem Jahr hat es wahrscheinlich noch 30 Euro
gekostet oder vor zwei.
Aber
ich glaube, ich kaufe mir noch einen zweiten
8-Gramm-Stick.
Für die Zukunft dann.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funzt.
Warum heißt es AI RootFS?
Oder heißt es eher UDFS?
Es heißt AI RootFS.
Aber was ist da dran AI?
Okay, das hat jetzt zumindest schon mal funktioniert.
Na, schauen wir mal.
80 Gramm.
Nicht 8 Gramm.
Von dem Jahr hat 97
Euro Ramstick mal unter 25
gekostet, ja
Yep, Clock
Das ist halt ziemlicher Mist
Okay, Leute
Ich sehe das schon, komm, das ist wieder so lahm
Ich hole mal hier meine
Meine KVM
Na, wobei, er macht was
Maus bewegt sich aber wieder nicht richtig
Äh, Lama ist fack
Oh, oh, oh, oh
Das war jetzt tatsächlich schneller als das letzte Mal
Das hat das letzte Mal gar nicht gemacht
Chatge, Chatge, Postchamp, Postchamp
Aber ich glaube immer noch
Ohne Mist, ich glaube immer noch, der hat Probleme
Mit den 4K
Da reicht dem der RAM irgendwie nicht mit 4K
Der swappt wahrscheinlich gerade wie verrückt im Hintergrund rum
Bin eben erst dazu gekommen
Wofür soll das eingesetzt werden?
Als Ersatz für meine Linux-VM
Okay, so. Ich mache jetzt mal hier die
USB ab.
Oder ich stelle den PC einfach hier rüber
zum Installieren. Das ist wahrscheinlich
einfacher.
Oh!
Chat, das ging schneller
als das letzte Mal jetzt.
Guck mal, das Ding bewegt sich auch.
Okay,
ich habe nichts gesagt.
Es bewegt sich nicht.
Aber wir geben dem nochmal
eine halbe Minute, eine halbe Minute Zeit.
Du hast Cache auch schon
mit 4G RAM installiert? Ja.
Aber hast du PXE gemacht
und quasi das komplette System
aus dem RAM laufen lassen? Wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Sus.
Äh, das will nicht.
Okay, dann nicht.
So, KVM, komm mal her.
Ähm, ich mach das anders.
Ich stöpsel das hier mal ab.
Die Maus mach ich auch ab.
Dann...
Moment.
Will er mich verarschen?
Jetzt, wo ich alles abgestöpselt habe, funktioniert es?
Na gut.
Wobei, der jebaitet mich bestimmt nur.
Der jebaitet mich.
Wie?
Display Configuration?
Lass mich mal runterstellen auf 1080p
Ne, das ist ja wirklich
Ich...
Boah, wie viel das rumleckt.
Ah, komm mal da!
Hä?
Was will es?
No K-Screen Backend found.
Please check your K-Screen
Installation.
Das ist nicht gut, oder?
Okay.
Mal gucken, ob er den Installer
launchen kann.
Launch Installer
Nee, nee, nee, nee
Wenn das jetzt schon so lahm ist, was meint ihr, wie lahm das ist beim Installieren?
Ähm, seht ihr
Ich schöpsel das jetzt ab
und schließe dann die KVM an, wir installieren einfach da drüber und dann mach ich wieder rückgängig.
Und dann kauf ich mir noch einen 8G-RAM-Stick.
Sind Kernel-Parameter möglich?
Ähm, wahrscheinlich, wenn man wüsst...
Nee, sind nicht möglich.
Weil ich boote das über PXE.
Und da sind die Kernel-Parameter schon fest drin.
Vielleicht sind auch meine Kernel-Parameter da sinnlos gewählt.
Gibt's keine Text-Based-Installation? Nee.
Aber wie gesagt, es liegt an meiner PX-Installation.
Ich wette mit euch, wenn ich das jetzt über das normale ISO mache,
flutscht das Git-Instant.
Ziehen wir das hier raus.
Zack.
Ausschalten.
Aus ist.
Abstöpseln.
Moment, jetzt muss ich hier nochmal den Strom abmachen.
Weil den brauche ich jetzt hier drüben.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Strom rausziehen
Das ist immer gefuddelt hier
Weil ich so viel Kabels rumliegen hab
So
Machen wir das hier
Da kommt das Ding jetzt hin hier
Oh, zack
Ähm, ich hab keinen Platz
Okay, ich muss das Ringlight ausschalten
Das ist aber egal. Wir brauchen das Ring Light eh nicht mehr.
So.
KVM kommt dran.
Ähm.
HDMI.
USB-C.
Strom.
Gut.
Ja, brauchen wir nicht.
Dann muss ich jetzt tatsächlich...
Jetzt voll durch die Brust ins Auge.
Ähm, ich muss jetzt hier hin
1.241.244 ist die KVM
Yes
Ne, ich hab noch keinen
Basteltisch
So, jetzt haben wir die KVM
Jetzt machen wir hier an
Sollte alles angeschlossen sein eigentlich
Aber mein Netzwerkkabel fehlt noch
Uuuuh
Moment, wo hab ich das Netzwerkkabel
hin
Das müsste doch hier irgendwo noch hängen.
Äh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Das hat schon mal nett funktioniert.
Kein Tastatur-Input möglich gewesen gerade.
Mal neu laden.
Wo ist meine...
Wo ist mein Netzwerkkabel denn jetzt hier auf einmal hin?
Da ist es.
Okay.
So nochmal einschalten und jetzt hoffen wir mal dass jetzt meine tastatur funktioniert über die kvm
Hallo tastatur da entering setup sehr gut
ok
Hier drüber nein was mache ich denn da bin ich dumm virtual media cache us linux desktop
Das hier wollen wir jetzt.
Wir wollen das mounten.
Mount to remote.
Image mounting.
Oder was?
Ne, was will ich?
Ich will cache US mounten.
Einfach sagen, mount to remote.
Und jetzt image mounting.
Das da.
Mount image.
Okay.
Boot override.
Und wie sagt man dem jetzt, dass der von CD booten soll?
Vielleicht muss ich nochmal neu starten.
Ups.
Virtual Media.
Toolbox.
Remote.
Restart.
So, jetzt sollte er hoffentlich checken, dass ich vom USB booten kann.
Ja, da, Flashdrive.
Excellent, Cache US.
Ja, jetzt checkt das wohl.
Jetzt funktioniert das auch ohne Probleme, weil jetzt ist nicht alles im RAM.
Jetzt flutscht das auch.
Guck mal, wie schnell das jetzt geht.
Gleich.
Wenn er da seine Cache-OS-Magic gemacht hat.
Also ich hab noch...
Also jetzt zu der Frage mit dem Basteltisch.
Ich hab ein neues...
Also ich hab hier ein Paket stehen
mit einem neuen Basteltisch drin.
Hab ich aber noch nicht aufgebaut,
weil ich hier noch nicht aufgeräumt hab drumherum
und deswegen so wenig Platz hab.
Ich schieb das Aufräumen schon seit 3-4 Wochen
So vor mir her
Und hab eigentlich
Auf der einen Seite Bock das mal alles wieder ordentlich
Zu machen aber auf der anderen Seite mich zu faul
Zum Aufräumen
Ich denke mal das
Kennt auch noch die ein oder anderen
Von euch
Der hat schon großartig Bock auf Aufräumen
Das hat man schon wie man klein war
Nicht gerne gemacht
So, CacheOS, dann zeig mal her, ob das jetzt besser funktioniert.
Ja, Leute, das geht schon mal, das geht schon mal deutlich schneller jetzt, oder?
Ja, das ist einfach zu wenig RAM.
Oder, oder das neue ISO ist Schrott.
Wie viel RAM sind gerade belegt?
Weiß nicht, können wir gucken.
R, I.
Was?
Warte.
Seit wann ist es free-h?
Seit wann gibt es free-h?
Ich mach immer 4-M.
Moment, Moment.
Okay, Magic.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, es ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger das...
Ja gut, aber überlegt mal.
Guck mal.
Es ist jetzt...
Es sind jetzt zwei Gig belegt.
Davor musste ich das komplette ISO im RAM entpacken.
Das wird schon ganz schön eng.
Ey, komm
British
British Englisch
Wobei
Ich komm da nicht auf die Idee
Ich will dann Pound und so Zeug verwenden
Ja, das wollen wir machen
So, hier
Evo, genau, da ist nämlich
CacheUS schon drauf
Das will ich eigentlich gar nicht ersetzen.
Hier, Samsung SSD.
Evo, Erase.
BTFS, Encrypt.
Ups.
Oh.
Moin.
Next.
Plasma Desktop, next.
Printer Support brauche ich nicht.
Next.
Stream.
Ne, Max.
Name for this computer.
Cache US. Ja, wunderbar.
Massive, highly secure password.
Install.
Install now.
So, jetzt sollte eigentlich
nichts passieren mit dem System,
das schon installiert ist.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
drauf.
Das müsste jetzt auch relativ zackig gehen.
Ja, geht eigentlich recht schnell.
Also, man muss mal sagen,
die CacheOS-Installation, die hält
sich im Rahmen, ja. Aber ich habe schon
deutlich schnellere Installationen gesehen. Also,
das schnellste Linux-Install ist CacheOS
nicht.
Aber es geht.
Ich hab freitags nicht frei, ich hab immer montags frei.
Freitags nicht.
Es ist ja auch viel schlauer so.
Montags sind die alle immer super motiviert und wollen alle was machen.
Und freitags ist eh schon jeder im Kopf im Urlaub.
Oder im Wochenende.
Oder woanders als auf der Arbeit.
Ah, Pfeifherd.
Finde ich auch.
Du wirst es genauso machen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich kann euch das übrigens alle nur empfehlen.
Wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt, Teilzeit beste.
Also wenn euch die Kohle ausreicht, Teilzeit beste.
Ja, lass dich nicht erwischen, Tommy.
Heißt denn dann im Bootmanager beide Installationen gleich oder zeigt er die Disc an?
Ich hoffe, er zeigt die Disc an.
Also im Bootmanager eh nicht, das muss ich über das BIOS machen.
Im Bootmanager steht dann immer nur die jeweilige Installation drin,
von der jeweiligen SSD, würde ich sagen.
Das müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren
Wie das dann funktioniert
Weil so ist mir das am liebsten
Dann habe ich die zwei Systeme komplett voneinander getrennt
Das zeigt dir das
Windows auf einer anderen SSD
Ich bin gespannt
Lass uns mal gucken
Mal schauen.
Ist der irgendwie ganz schön lahm gerade beim Downloaden?
Kann das sein?
Oder auch nicht.
Nö, ist er nicht.
Ist er nicht.
Der hat bloß nicht alles angezeigt.
Ja, Chad, ich weiß, Montag 13.50 Uhr
nicht die beste Zeit zum Streamen.
Aber was willst du machen, ne?
Ja, ich bin wieder da
So bis, ich denke mal bis 16 Uhr oder so
In dem Dreh
Werde ich da sein
Bis dahin sollten wir das aber alles locker eingerichtet haben
Hoffe ich mal
Übrigens diesen Krampf mit SSH-Unlock
Mach ich diesmal nicht, ich stopp'sle eh ne Tastatur an
Und dann WOW
wie kommst du da drauf ich habe lange nicht mal eingeloggt in woche
dann gibt es einen stream drucker wir haben letztens in meinen laser drucker
eingerichtet unter linux das ging wieder erwartend ziemlich problemlos und schnell
ich glaube problematisch wird es nur wenn es nicht problemlos und schnell
geht dann art es komplett aus habe ich nicht rf programmer steht aber noch auf dem plan
so jetzt müsste er gleich fertig sein und dann restart so und dann stöpseln wir es jetzt gleich
wieder oben an die Elgato Capture Karte und schau mal
wie das ist mit 240
FPS oder 240
Hertz.
Refresh Rate.
Was ist denn? Paper Cut?
So, jetzt schau mal mal, wenn ich jetzt hier ins
Bios gehe, was ich zur Auswahl habe.
Zum Booten. Also,
ich hab Lima...
Ach, guck mal hier.
Da steht die SSD dahinter.
Okay, dann ist easy.
Dann ist easy.
Guck mal, ich bote jetzt mal von der Evo-SSD.
Der checkt das.
Und guck mal, der zeigt mir nicht das Cache-US von der anderen Installation an.
Okay.
Gut.
dann würde ich mal sagen,
machen wir das hier mal ab.
Ja, ja.
Und stöpseln es wieder
dran
an die eigentliche Capture Card.
Und gucke mal, wie das jetzt funktioniert.
Zack.
Strom raus hier.
Netzwerkkabel ab.
USV ab.
Warum sage ich eigentlich immer USV anstatt KVM?
Das ist richtig hängengeblieben.
Das hat mit der USV überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Kegweight.
So, angestöpselt ist es.
HDMI-Kabel dran.
Netzwerk-Kabel dran.
Und einmal zum Auswählen Tastatur dran.
Ups.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Da habt ihr aber Glück gehabt, Chat.
Chat, da habt ihr richtig Glück gehabt.
Ich bin gerade auf meinen Ausschalterknopf gekommen
vom Streaming-PC.
Seid ihr noch da?
Alles noch da, ja?
Monka S.
Gut, dass Windows so langsam ist und es nicht checkt.
Gut, dass Windows das nicht so schnell checkt.
Omega Lul.
Knappe Sache.
Knappe Kiste, wie manche Boomer sagen.
Okay.
CashUS, da sind wir.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das ist.
Wenn man jetzt hier 240 Hertz einstellt und ob das dann auch alles funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Okay, ey, schaltet schon mal direkt auf 4K.
Das ist schon mal richtig dumm.
mal gucken ob er wieder auf 4k
aber 4k auf dem 1080p monitor ist nicht so nice sie ist ja auch wie schept das hier
alles aussieht und wie verkehrt das aussieht display configuration so 1920 x 1080 240
die maus die ist so smooth jetzt bei 240 hertz richtig pock so das hier machen wir
erstmal runter auf 100%.
Ja, so ist das nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Exzellent.
Ne, ne, HDR
enable ich nicht.
So ist das gut. So, und jetzt mal gucken,
ob das hier die checkt. Guck mal,
240, da haben wir es doch.
Ansonsten eigentlich alles
default lassen. Sehr gut, sehr gut.
So, dann müssen wir jetzt noch ein paar andere Kleinigkeiten erledigen.
Nämlich, wir müssen...
...Deskflow starten.
No.
Ähm, use this computer.
Start.
Was?
Wie jetzt?
Läuft das vielleicht noch?
Läuft das vielleicht noch auf dem anderen irgendwie?
Ah, hier, guck mal, hier läuft noch
Deskflow-Gedöns.
Deskflow.
Deskflow-Core.
Wobei...
Ja, der kommt da nicht hin.
Mein User hat da keine Berechtigung drauf, ne?
Kann das sein?
Mein User hat da keine...
Ah, das ist wieder auch so dumm.
Warum ist das nicht?
Oder doch?
Ja, der darf darauf nicht schreiben.
Ja, das ist ja mal wieder richtig hängen geblieben gemacht.
dass man das Programm von verschiedenen
Usern aus benutzen kann,
aber
die Config...
Wie das richtig hängen geblieben ist.
Wie gut läuft HDR eigentlich unter Linux?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Okay, kann man jetzt hier...
Okay, Windows-Logik.
Also ich kann das hier nicht
not for right öffnen,
sagt er mir.
Warum nicht?
Also ich kann das hier
writeen. Ist gar kein Problem.
Kann ich das hier not for write
öffnen?
Ah, das kann ich nicht
for write öffnen. Okay.
Ja, aber das ist ja mal richtig hängen geblieben, dass
der die gleiche Config benutzt.
Okay.
Dann muss ich hier dem irgendwie
erlauben. Leute, Windows
Windows Settings. Wie geht das jetzt? Details,
Security,
Max
und Users.
Äh,
Max, Users, äh,
Write, ähm,
Edit.
Ey, jetzt kommt Windows-Geschiss, man.
Äh, Users,
Allow, Write.
So?
Geht das jetzt?
Deskflow?
Okay
Das war's, das war das Problem
Sowas sollte aber eigentlich im User-Home-Verzeichnis liegen, gell
Kann man das hier vielleicht einstellen, wo er seine Config
Ja, wo das Zertifikat liegt
Aber man kann nicht einstellen
Wo er seine
Das ist schon irgendwie doof, ne
Ach hier
So
Mach PR.
Wir können...
Enable the setting will disable server GUI.
Ne.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Na gut.
dann dann nicht also konflikt server ist okay das muss man auf lassen sondern gehen jetzt hier
mal rüber das initiale setup ist halt ein bisschen ein bisschen paint paint champ ich ja etwas paint
schämpfe denn jetzt müssen wir erst mal hier auf der kiste die tastatur sharing software installieren
mit diesem hässlichen Terminal
mit was
Transparency hat
dass man eigentlich gar nichts mehr sieht
So, also, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
gucken
Haru, wir installieren jetzt erstmal
einen Package Manager, mit dem ich klarkomme
Yes.
Okay.
Desk Flow.
Cache US Desk Flow.
Yes.
Was war die Lösung für den doppelten Mauszeiger?
Du wirst es gleich sehen.
Du musstest das installieren.
Nicht die Portable Version benutzen.
Und noch was anderes machen.
aber wie gesagt, noch haben wir das ja gar nicht.
Start.
So, Deskflow starten.
No, keine Updates checken.
Jetzt würde ich sagen,
make this computer
zu 122.134
glaube ich.
Connect.
Yes.
Äh.
So, jetzt muss ich
Jetzt muss ich hier rüber
Und das noch accepten
Accept, yes
Alter
Pack mich nicht ab, man
Kack, kack, Software, man
Fingerprint does not match trusted fingerprints.
Ja, ach, wie?
Das hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht.
Okay, stopp.
Okay, wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mache?
kann man nicht sagen wartet mal rename so warum immer das gut rechte brauchst
so und jetzt starte ich das noch mal jetzt nehme ich nichts da wenn man hier
start
Ich habe bis da jetzt langsam echt kein Bock mehr auf so komische...
Unable to write.
Achso, weil der keine Rechte...
Oh mein Gott, ist das eklig.
Aber ganz ehrlich, sowas sollte nicht global gespeichert sein.
Sowas muss in das Heimatverzeichnis.
Und nicht für mehrere User geshared.
Das kannst du so überhaupt nicht benutzen.
Okay, Users, Edit.
Users, Write.
Hoffe, das funzt jetzt.
Escflow.
Falsches Verzeichnis?
Echt jetzt?
Nee, oder?
Jetzt geht's.
Okay, Shios, hier.
Okay.
Okay, so.
Das hat funktioniert.
Jetzt muss ich hier noch festlegen.
Configure Server.
Hotkeys.
Add Hotkey.
Also.
hotkey machen wir jetzt mal wir hatten das letzte mal auch schon aber hier kommt
kein mensch benutzt hotkey ist für wenn hotkey ist press switch to computer ja
hier zu meinem jetzt war das nächste hotkey alte nutzt auch kein mensch
switch switch zu computer cash ios ok schauen wir mal
da sind wir leute da sind wir und jetzt wieder zurück so und jetzt kommt jetzt
Jetzt kommt Trick 17.
Massive, massive
Trick.
Guck mal, jetzt ist die Maus nämlich weg hier,
in der Mitte.
Jetzt muss ich noch in meine Settings hier.
Du kannst auch F13 simulieren.
Ja, ist wurscht.
So. Und jetzt gehen wir
in die Logitech Software.
Jetzt kommt
Advanced Shit.
Kann man das hier nicht einfach zumachen?
Jetzt kommt
advanceder Kram.
Also, Moment, Moment. Jetzt machen wir das mal so.
Das hier, so wie ich das dann später haben will.
Open Fullscreen auf dem
zweiten Desktop. Also, hier kommt
das weg. So, jetzt machen wir die Logitech
Software auf.
Und gucken jetzt Makros für die
Tastatur.
Makros.
switch 1 switch 2 ok sowas in der richtung haben wir ja schon
switch 2 marco da habe ich das editieren vielleicht so zur abwechslung es ist nicht
das löschen wir alles also was will ich haben keystrokes record keys to us ich will
rüber switchen auf den desktop und dann alt drücken
stopp standard delays kann man da 1 1 oder was ist das ok 25 ist das kleinste
Äh, no thanks.
Das darf ich nämlich nicht safe drücken.
Auch geil, oder?
Also von der Idee her sollte ich jetzt...
Ja, guck mal. Funzt.
So, das Zurück-Switchen hat noch funktioniert.
Noch nicht ganz, aber immerhin.
So, Switch 1 müssen wir jetzt editieren.
So, und da wollen wir jetzt, um zurück zu switchen...
wollen wir jetzt
Alt-Ö
und nach links.
Stop.
Save.
So, und wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe,
dann
kann ich jetzt dazwischen hin und her schalten.
Ich muss das noch übrigens vertauschen.
Was ist denn los ey
Okay es funktioniert
Nice
Guck mal jetzt kann ich wie bei meiner Linux VM
Kann ich dazwischen umschalten
Ich kann jetzt
F1 drücken
Ich switch auf den Desktop
Ich kann F2 drücken und ich bin auf meiner Linux, äh, nicht Linux VM.
Meine echte Linux-Kiste am Start.
Das ist nice.
So, jetzt können wir anfangen hier, nachdem das jetzt...
Moment, das ist das allerwichtigste.
Launch.
Äh, Auto-Start.
Da muss das rein.
Äh, hier, das kommt auf jeden Fall schon mal raus.
Auto-Start.
Add new.
Application.
Deskflow.
weil wir müssen jetzt mal noch gleich
gucken, ob das auch alles funktioniert.
Okay, also das sollte das jetzt automatisch
starten alles.
Dann geht das hier auf.
Achso, genau, dann brauchen wir jetzt noch
Preferences.
Enable
WL Clipboard Support,
dass ich Copy-Pasten kann.
Achso, ja das hat er jetzt rausgeschickt.
Configure Client.
Formalint.
So, jetzt müssen wir noch...
Desktop will continue in background.
Ja, ja. So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
ein ordentliches Terminal installieren.
Sonst mit aller Kritik drehe ich durch.
Ähm, Westterm.
Westterm.
Yes.
Ja, ich habe zum einen meine Config noch nicht drüber, aber immerhin ist das so schon mal besser.
So, jetzt kommt das Allerwichtigste, Leute. Das ist wirklich essentiell.
Ich muss erst mal kurz gucken, wie es mit meiner Tastatur und meinen Grafikkarten,
ne nicht mit der Tastatur, mit der Rammauslastung von der Grafikkarte aussieht.
4 gig
was
äh
aber da sind es total 7,1
muss man das jetzt verstehen
keine ahnung
muss ich nicht verstehen das funktioniert
so jetzt kommt das aller wichtigste
effects weil ohne geht es schon mal gar nicht
effects
wobbly windows
so
Jetzt bin ich zufrieden, so kann das bleiben
Muss ich hier noch meine
Konfig und so dann gleich rüber kopieren
Zack
Dann machen wir mal meine VM hier an
Wo ich mir gleich mal die Konfigs von ziehen kann
Stream VM
Da muss ich dann mal schauen, dass ich
SSH da
anmache drauf
und mich dann da einloggen kann
Max
Top Secret Passwort, kommt hier nie drauf
So, dann muss ich jetzt hier mal meine ganzen Konfigs runterkopieren
Und wir müssen jetzt auch KDE und sowas
anpassen
So, Firefox, warum starte ich Firefox?
Ich brauche kein Firefox
eigentlich nur ein terminal habe ich ssh laufen nicht start ssh die jetzt habe ich es laufen
okay das habe ich für eine ip schauen wir mal ob copy copy paste muss ich ja noch installieren
2, 1, 4, 6
Copy, Paste
WL Clipboard brauchen wir noch
Warum eigentlich von der VM zu Action Hardware
Bockt oder
Beides, oh warte mal das ist falsch
Beides ein bisschen, der Hauptgrund ist
Dass Wayland in der VM halt
Nicht gescheit funktioniert
Von gar nicht bis nicht gescheit
Und ich sehe das
Über die nächsten Jahre kommen
Dass X immer weiter
Ausgefaced wird
deswegen
jetzt mal echte Kiste.
Hat auch einen weiteren Vorteil.
So Sachen wie
Hardware Decoding
und sowas funktioniert. Wir müssen übrigens
gerade nochmal gucken, wenn wir schon da sind, bevor ich
das mache, wie so die Verzögerung
ist bei Audio.
Moment. Origin.
Ublock.
Origin. Das ist das
aller, aller, aller, aller wichtigste.
Das Ganze ist komplett
vergessen.
Mal gucken, ob der Sound
funktioniert.
Hallo?
YouTube funktioniert ja gerade erstklassig.
So.
Und hört man was gleich?
Moment, Moment.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels.
U-Block muss erstmal seine Dinger machen.
Hey, man hört was.
Das Ganze kam nämlich gestern raus.
Und das Soundfot.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Audio, Video, Sync-Test.
Mal gucken, wie gut die Verzögerung ist vom Sound.
Lass mal kurz checken.
Nee.
Geht komplett klar für das,
dass das gerade komplett über die Capture-Card läuft.
Das geht komplett klar.
Das ist 30, 40 Millisekunden Audioverzögerung.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Da erkennst du noch nicht mal.
Ich habe vorhin gesehen, das gucken wir jetzt nicht an.
Aber von dem gucke ich immer Videos.
Habe ich vorhin gesehen, dass er ein neues Hochklaren hat.
Gleich mal gucken, ob die Lippen so kommen.
Leute, Mund zu Audio passt top.
Das ist wie du sitzt vor der Kiste.
Du merkst nicht, dass das Audio und das Video durch die Capture Card geht.
Ich meine bei einem Game vielleicht.
Ja, wenn du da jetzt irgendwie CS spielen würdest oder sowas.
Aber für was anderes, ne.
Ne, wirklich nicht.
Merkst du nichts von.
Das ist das Funst.
Ja, das Funst sogar mit 240 Hertz.
Das ist ja das Geile.
Guck mal.
Wie schön flüssig das hier mit 240 Hertz wobbelt.
Ist das nicht geil?
Oh, das Wichtigste habe ich fast vergessen hier.
Mein Mauszeiger.
So, wir müssen jetzt erst einmal installieren.
5.
Clipboard.
WL Clipboard Git.
Damit Copy-Paste ordentlich funktioniert.
Hier kommen nicht nur 60 Hertz an.
Bei euch kommen 48 an.
Ja, das Linux-Desktop.
Ich sag's noch einmal, ich hab's gestern auch öfters gesagt.
Wir waren noch nie so nah dran
am Jahr des Linux-Desktops
wie 2026.
Aber auch 2026 wird nicht
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops sein.
So, jetzt haben wir auch Copy-Paste.
Also quasi hier Cross-System-Copy-Paste.
Guck, kann ich euch zeigen.
Wir machen jetzt hier, schreiben wir irgendeinen Mist rein.
Copy-Paste ich das.
Gehe rüber in meine VM und
Das geht nicht.
Habe ich das überhaupt eingeschaltet?
Vielleicht muss ich nochmal neu starten.
Das kann sein, dass ich nochmal neu starten muss.
Aber hier, WL Clipboard ist...
Schreibt der was von Clipboard hier?
Ne.
Clipboard was updated, okay.
Ah.
Moment.
Äh.
Was zum?
Onks?
Ich glaube, der spackt gerade ein bisschen um.
Äh.
Chat, wir haben es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was ich gemacht habe, aber ich habe es irgendwie zerstört.
Guck mal, Westerm will nicht mehr starten.
Aber Alakriti startet noch, okay.
Ah, jetzt startet Westerm auch wieder.
Nun gut.
Okay, schauen wir nochmal.
Copy, paste.
Ja, Funst, guck.
Copy, paste, Funst.
So.
Ja, dann haben wir doch hier schon was.
Jetzt können wir das ordentlich anpassen.
Was ist denn das hier unten?
Okay, da klickt man drauf und es...
geht weg.
Bluetooth enabled.
Enable Wi-Fi aus.
Clipboard.
Ja, hat doch funktioniert.
Was auch immer das da unten drunter ist.
So, jetzt müssen wir KDE noch ein bisschen gescheit einstellen.
Als erstes, passt es eurer Meinung nach von der Helligkeit vom Desktop?
Oder soll ich das Gamma noch ein bisschen hochstellen?
Also ich würde sagen, es passt eigentlich ganz gut.
Es ist jetzt kein großer Unterschied zur VM.
RGB Range Full.
Limited.
Okay.
Automatic.
Whatever.
Color Profile brauchen wir nicht.
HDR mache ich nicht an, weil wenn ich HDR anmache, geht die 240 Hertz Capture Sache nicht mehr.
übrigens ich finde es richtig nice dass so viele von euch dabei sind montags 14
uhr 19 gar nicht damit gerechnet aber ich gefällt der stream auch wenn ein
bisschen anruf schwierigkeiten hatten können sie jetzt auch voller klicken
wenn ich voller geklickt hat sei das nächste mal wieder direkt live mit am
start night light machen wir an sunrise sunset checkt automatisch gut
So, als erstes, wie kriege ich diesen dummen Abstand hier unten weg?
Hm, hm.
Show Panel Configuration?
Set Position?
Floating?
Aha, Disabled.
Guck mal da.
Jetzt hängt es immer schön da unten in der Ecke.
So wie das sein muss.
Und viel größer muss das auch nicht sein.
Das ist gut. Jetzt hängt das immer da in der Ecke.
So, Virtual Desktops müssen jetzt eingeblendet werden.
Und zwar brauchen wir 1, 2, 3, 4 Stück erstmal.
Jetzt muss ich einstellen.
Switch, Virtual Desktop.
Wie macht man das?
Sportcuts wahrscheinlich?
Desktop.
window management switch to the aha aha aha ok switch to desktop ok switch to desktop 1
shortcut das kann man raus machen das da es wird aktuell benutzt für active test manager
re-assign.
Next. Das da.
Add.
Shift 2.
Meta 2.
Weg damit. Add.
Input.
3.
Switch to Desktop 4.
Weg damit.
4.
Apply. Okay. Desktop Switch aus.
Am Start.
Das ist schon mal gut, das brauche ich, weil
dann kann ich hier Fullscreen
meinen Browser aufmachen.
Ah, ich brauche noch was. Was ist
Anwendung in Anwendung
maximieren?
Äh, Chat.
Ich habe es zerstört.
Ich habe es geschafft, die Settings zu
crashen.
Shortcuts.
Maximize.
Maximize
win maximal meter page ab weg damit f so sehr gut das heißt nämlich im endeffekt ich kann
jetzt hier den browser aufmachen fullscreen ich gehe auf den zweiten desktop western
Irgendwie ist Westterm kaputt, wenn ich das hier drüber starte. Warum?
What the fuck, Alter?
Wayland XD HD?
So, jetzt habe ich mein Kram hier. Browser auf dem ersten Desktop.
wichtigstes ich wollte unix porn schreiben
bestes subreddit
so dann ach wir haben immer noch das problem dass in west term der cursor nicht stimmt noch
mal als nächstes zsh ist installt wie war das noch mal change shell minus i zsh kann das sein
oder muss man das ganze... Minus S ist es. Ich bin Bash. Bin User bin ZSH. User bin ZSH. Okay.
Western
Ah ja gut
Alter was hat er denn hier für tausend Sachen
R-F ZSH
Punkt RC
C und und und
Wobei das überschreiben wir jetzt einfach
Also CP Max
At
Also das ist meine VM
Punkt ZSHRC
Hier hin
Yes.
Wunderbar, hat er kopiert.
Jetzt nochmal kurz gucken.
Western.
Okay, das schon mal
auch nicht besser.
Doch, ist besser.
Ist besser.
Es fehlen bloß ein paar Sachen noch.
Was fehlt ist
except
ich muss noch
installieren
äh
was ist, ey, das Western ist voll am Abspacken, man
was ist denn hier los
Starship muss ich noch installieren
Starship
und ich muss noch
Terminal automatisch starten
Western
ok, es sieht
immer besser aus langsam, äh
Die Farbe stimmt nicht, Leute
Achso, ich habe meine Starship-Config ja nicht dabei
Achso, ich habe die Starship-Config noch gar nicht kopiert
Ähm
Mal hier
SCP, ich muss mal kurz hier schauen
Wo ich die liegen habe
Konfig
Starship-Tommel.
Und wo liegt Westerm?
Config.
Westerm. Westerm. Westerm.
Lua. Okay, die zwei Sachen
kopieren wir. Übrigens, mein Mauszeiger stimmt immer noch
nicht. Das ist ziemlicher Sack.
Mal gucken,
ob wir den Mauszeiger irgendwie gefixt kriegen, ohne
Westerm wieder auf X11 umzustellen.
SCP. So.
Hier.
da kopieren wir jetzt starship tommel nach config starship tommel
browser profile ja wird es nicht nicht verkehrt starship
ich hab jetzt habe ich zugemacht okay das sieht schon mal besser aus dann vor
mtm kann man raus schmeißen ganz ehrlich guckt nicht der terraform
kann drinnen bleiben was mecker da sonst noch den odeno benutzt
überhaupt einer dino kann auch raus was kann ich noch drin stehen hat
und aus irgendwelchen gründen ist auch ein konto unten der überhaupt nicht mehr
ausgeführt wird
weil das muss doch gar nicht so zu installieren
jetzt habe ich immer eine terminal die western config habe ich noch nicht scp
wie war das mkdir config western und jetzt scp config west term western lua
lua
ja das ist doch schon mal angenehmer guck mal jetzt sieht es fast wieder aus wie auf
meiner normalen
VM hier.
Passt.
Aber
sieht schon ähnlich aus, oder?
Nicht viel Unterschied.
So.
Cube CTL installieren.
Brauchen wir bestimmt nochmal irgendwann.
Was übrigens auch cool ist, wie er hier
Snapshots macht.
Oh, und wichtig, wichtig.
Ich muss noch in den Settings einstellen, dass Windows-Taste Enter mein Terminal startet.
Was ist euer Lieblings-Shortcut zum Terminal starten?
Bei mir ist es Windows-Taste Enter.
Wie sieht das bei euch aus?
Add new application.
Habt ihr auch sowas?
Same.
Host T.
Was ist Host für eine Taste?
Windows-T
Ctrl-Alt-T, Super-T
Okay, bei mir ist es
Windows-Taste, Enter
Default-Shortcuts
Äh, Enter
Ha!
Excellent
Kann man bei KDE irgendwie einstellen, dass
Programme standardmäßig
im Fullscreen gestartet werden?
Das würde mich
in der Tat mal interessieren
まあまあまあ
まあ
Settings, Window Management, Windows Rule, by adding a new Reset, Maximize.
Okay.
Ich mag KDE immer mehr.
Also, was soll ich, wo soll ich hin?
Window Management, da sind wir schon.
Window Rule.
Äh.
Ach, Moment, ich hab das Falsche.
Ich hab das Falsche auf.
Window Man.
Hier gehen wir mal in Settings.
Window?
Gibt es das?
まあ
Was ist bei Julian?
Alt F3?
Ist Alt F3 die
System, die Settings?
Special Application
Setting, Window Rules.
rules rules hier window rules at new das window class match okay jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt wie das funktioniert description western max sie meist so
window klar wo soll ich denn wissen wie das ding match hole window class yes no
detect window properties jetzt kann ich das window anklicken ok moment muss
ich hier auch noch mal starten detect window properties wobei ganz ehrlich das ist eine
dumme idee das ist eine dumme idee was ich vorhaben das ist eine dumme idee
vergesst das will ich doch nicht eine blöde idee gewesen weil es kann doch
durchaus mal sein dass ich west haben hier irgendwie so floating oben drüber
haben will und nicht nicht full screen ja dann dann mache ich dann dann lieber
so dass es wobei auf der anderen seite man kann doch bestimmt kann man nicht
irgendwie sagen edit application oder sowas und dann sagen pull screen
advanced running terminal nee anscheinend nicht aber es gibt doch
bestimmt sowas wie west term was ist denn west term und west term gui
genau das gleiche minus minus help start gibt es da nämlich sowas wie maxima ist
doch bestimmt oder
ja always new process new tab position attached domain
ach komm scheiß drauf ist einmal einmal wurde ich den computer laufen habe einmal hier full
screen drücken mit dem short katz kein problem übrigens fehlt mir noch was ich muss noch mal
in die Settings.
Hier, das da brauchen wir.
Das Startmenü.
Shortcuts.
Das soll mit
Windows-Taste D gestartet werden.
Wie nennt man das Ding? Launcher?
K-Runner?
Ist es K-Runner?
Alt-Space.
Oh, was ist denn das?
K-Runner!
Dann brauchen wir dieses dumme Startmenü gar nicht
Okay, das ist in der Tat ganz cool
Das ist quasi sowas wie Rofi nur in KDE integriert
Irgendwie cool, oder?
KDE macht echt Pluspunkte bei mir, muss ich sagen
KDE ist wirklich der beste Linux-Desktop
Also so als komplette Desktop-Umgebung
So, dann kriegt das aber nochmal einen neuen Shortcut.
Peak Desktop braucht keiner.
Guck mal hier.
Jetzt kann ich einfach hier hingehen.
So, Kontrolle, Westterm.
Bam.
Easy.
Um nicht zu sagen...
Easy as fuck.
So, jetzt machen wir hier unten die Leiste nach oben hin, weil ich das gewöhnt bin von I3.
Ey, Chat, ich war jetzt hier ziemlich beschäftigt mit Basteln.
Wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen habt, ich habe es übersehen, schreibt es einfach nochmal rein.
Mit Entwuppelos davor.
Position. Set Position.
Aha.
Und schon ist es oben. Eats.
Ja, das ist doch nice.
So ist das. So gefällt
mir das. Jetzt mal ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das sieht doch fast aus.
Das sieht doch fast aus wie mein E3 Setup, oder?
Kaum ein Unterschied.
Kaum ein größerer Unterschied.
Wobblons. Chat.
Twitch.
wir brauchen noch ffz aller wichtigste überhaupt
zack chat chat pop out copy paste
guck mal der zeigt noch das andere an
So und jetzt müssen wir hier FFZ, Firefox, dass wir ordentliche Emotes haben.
Add to Firefox.
Add.
Pin to Toolbar.
Jawoll!
Da sind wir.
Die größer machen.
und jetzt settings ffz control center addons bei der twitch team 7 tv im mons und bei der
twitch tv im mons sagt das kann es aber ausprobieren keck business jetzt sollte es funktionieren
Fuck
Kunst
Es sieht ein bisschen sehr pixelig aus
Und nicht scharf, oder?
Sieht ein bisschen ausgefranst aus
Das liegt bestimmt anti
Kann man hier anti-alessing umstellen?
Das ist ja immer ein bisschen
Paintschamp unter Linux
die erlässlich aus macht überhaupt keinen unterschied
roh auf 2
warum was was bringt das dann so pixel rendering
Ich sehe da keinen Unterschied, Leute.
Für mich ist das kein Unterschied.
Dann ist die Virtual Desktop-Anzeige
ja tagsüber nicht so breit.
Okay.
Wobei, ich muss mich dran gewöhnen
Hier einfach Settings
Und dann
Virtual
Virtual Desktops
Raw
Ah
Ne, das gefällt mir nicht
Ich, dann, dann soll es so
Ich meine, ich habe ja bei E3 hier auch die Anzeige
Oh ne, das ist okay, ich meine, davon haben sie ja nicht
Ich brauche ja hier nichts von der Leiste hier oben, ich klicke ja da eh nicht drauf
Außer vielleicht mal für den da
Hast du schon eine Idee für die Snapshots?
Wieso? Ich lasse den einfach standardmäßig
Snapshots snappen
So, ähm
Was mich immer noch ein bisschen abfuckt, ist die Geschichte, dass ich, dass mein Mauszeiger hier dann stimmt.
Sowas nervt mich extrem.
Wir müssen mal kurz gucken, Westerm, gibt es davon vielleicht eine neuere Version von Westerm?
Westerm Git?
Na, selbst kompilieren will ich Westerm jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Gibt es Nightly Bin?
Das ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht.
wobei wir gucken wir probieren sie mal kurz aus wir gehen ihr github western releases
das ist ja im stream läuft auch gut da ist da ruckelt nix und so das läuft alles super
flüssig nightly will ich haben wo finden wo finde ich hier night nightly western nightly
Western Nightly Builds
Nightly
Raw Image
Ach hier, guck mal
releases download nightly
releases nightly
er wird
hat mal western von wo zieht er das hier
ach du hast was gefunden jetzt gucken wir mal chat chat mal gucken ob das copy
pasten funst ich kopiere jetzt von maxi die adresse guckt die habe ich gerade
kopiert. Jetzt gehen wir mal hier rüber.
Funst. Copy-Paste
Champ.
Nightly.
Nightly. Boah, Alter.
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Wie viele Nightly-Releases hat
denn Windows, Ubuntu?
Ja, Nightly, Ubuntu, klingt erstmal gar
nicht so verkehrt. Ich meine, wir haben zwar kein Ubuntu,
aber 14.04.
Debian, Ubuntu App Image,
OpenSUSE, Fedora,
aber kein
Keine Art Linux
Aber das könnte man hier übers Aua machen
Downloads
Weget
Ta
Westerm
Okay, schauen wir mal
Westerm User
Ne, nicht Share, Bin
Westerm
Oh, guck mal
Jet, der checkt's.
Die neue Nightly-Version von Westerm
checkt's. Der Mauszeiger ist richtig.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Aber eine Sache,
die mich nervt, ist,
wir haben auf einmal hier oben
eine Leiste.
Wer will denn sowas?
Wer will denn sowas hier?
Ihh, ihh.
Geh weg.
Für die leiste ausblenden und in meiner config hier ich habe auch keine leiste drin
Deswegen wundert mich da hat sich bestimmt was geändert in der config muss man gucken wie man bei dem neuen western messi jetzt den
wegmacht
Wie du machst
Wie du machst einfach bist doch bär metal unterwegs hast du btfs ja ich habe btfs und er macht auto snapshots
jedes mal wenn ich was installieren wegen dem pin mit dem pin nichts zu tun
das kann man bestimmt ausblenden hier start domain attach workspace class
auto connect ist nicht okay western west
oder kann man das mit mit mit window rules heizt titelbar window decoration
decoration serie habe ich doch schon ausgeschaltet
kd kann das ausblenden ja das machen wir weil ich habe hier guck mal western
decorations habe ich auf einen anstehen und das funs anscheinend nicht
Was?
If you just want to remove the title bar, set window decorations resize.
Okay, das machen wir mal kurz.
Das vielleicht irgendwas.
Ah, äh...
Was für eine Hässlichkeit ist das denn hier jetzt?
Okay, ich bleib bei...
Oh, meine WimRC fehlt auch.
SCP?
WimRC?
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, wie man Tasten-Repeat in KDE ordentlich einstellen kann?
Wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie über die System-Settings.
Okay.
Ah, jetzt.
Exit.
Rechts...
Was sagst du?
Rechts-Klick auf die Leiste.
Okay.
More Actions?
No Titlebar and Frame!
Ja, exquisite.
Excellent, excellent.
Ja, das gefällt mir gut.
Dann würde ich sagen,
ich habe es,
das ist gecrashed gerade, habt ihr das gesehen?
Das ist gerade gecrashed.
Das will ich aber nicht hoffen,
dass es öfters crasht.
Aber jetzt crasht es nicht mehr.
Okay.
Was auch immer das gerade für Probleme hatte.
Na gut.
Okay. Also hier haben wir Westterm am Start.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch Windows Rules einstellen gleich.
Dass das immer weg bleibt.
Also Home, Max, Downloads,
Westterm, Userbin, Westterm.
Dann würde ich sagen,
deinstallieren wir Westterm
tatsächlich jetzt mal an der Stelle.
So, Westterm deinstallieren.
GTF Jetbrains
Mono.
Das lasse ich tatsächlich mal drauf.
Wenn das aus irgendwelchen Gründen gebraucht wird,
dann
dann machen wir das doch jetzt mal.
Lassen wir das mal drauf.
Schade, es ist eh eine gute Schriftart.
so und jetzt moment sekunde ich kann jetzt habe ich western installt und kann es gar nicht kriegst
gar nicht mehr gestartet mit moment wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit neue anwendungen wie kann
man so eine art shortcut erstellen wacke wartet mal moment das hat mir doch irgendwie short
Shortcuts
und dann hier
Add New Application
und wir wollen nicht Application, wir wollen Command
or Script.
Ja, weil hier ist es nicht drin, ne?
Wir wollen hier Command
or Script, Command, das da.
Okay.
Äh, whatever.
Okay, das sind so Sachen, die sollten nicht sein.
Add command or script.
Dann wählen wir das mal hier drüber aus.
Okay.
Bin.
Hä?
Ach, Script Files.
Wie jetzt?
Kann ich nicht.
Kann ich nicht direkt?
Oh, Sound.
Muss ich da jetzt ein Bash-File
für anlegen?
Oder was?
Weil Application selbst geht ja nicht.
Der Browse-Button soll ich klicken.
Wo ist der Browse Button? Ach das ist der Browse Button.
Okay.
Ja so geil ist es jetzt nicht.
Wenn ich keine Custom Anwendung da hinzufügen kann, das ist ein bisschen...
Suckt ein wenig.
Muss mir hässliches Alakriti verwenden gerade nochmal.
Reboot.
kann nicht sein dass wir dafür rebooten müssen. Westterm, wir machen jetzt ein Bash-Skript
einfach daneben. User bin, Wim, start.sh, bin, bash, westterm, seamod, plus x, start,
start und okay dann shortcuts noch mal probieren
command of script schuss dann wollen wir noch mal also downloads western user bin startpunkt sh
Was hat der?
Was will er denn?
Error while communicating with global shortcut service.
Ist der jetzt gecrashed oder was?
Soll ich jetzt rebooten?
Okay, ich reboote jetzt.
Reboot.
Also wenn man für sowas rebooten muss, ist das ziemlich doof.
Aha, es rebootet.
Excellent.
Ah, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist die falsche Kiste.
Hehe.
Der hat jetzt mein anderes
Linux gestartet. Okay.
Ich muss erstmal in Bootmanager jedes Mal.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm. Wie gesagt, ich will ja explizit,
dass es getrennt ist, die zwei
Systeme, auf zwei unterschiedlichen SSDs.
Also das ist schon okay.
Das heißt, ich muss dann hier immer auswählen.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Meint ihr, Chat, was meint ihr?
Funktioniert es jetzt?
Nach dem Reboot?
Also mit dem Shortcut?
Weil ich meine, das muss ja schon irgendwie möglich...
Oh, ich kack nur.
Ich habe mich vertippt.
Wie kann man sich bei 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 vertippen?
So, schauen wir mal, ob die Auflösung stimmt.
Ob der auch jetzt
Deskflow und so startet.
Ah, ich habe noch eine Sache vergessen.
Ganz wichtig. Automatischer
Login. Muss ich noch einschalten.
Ja, guck mal.
Er startet es schon richtig.
Automatischer Login.
Desktop-File wäre auch eine Option.
Ja gut, aber ich meine,
Das andere sollte schon auch tun.
Wir müssen Auto-Login einschalten.
Wahrscheinlich Login-Screen?
Automatically login as user.
Max.
KDE Wallet.
Ja, das interessiert mich nicht.
Okay, gut.
So.
Dann schauen wir jetzt hier nochmal.
Shortcuts.
Was war das?
Web Search Keywords.
Shortcuts.
Add.
Ah, wisst ihr, was sein kann, dass das Probleme hat?
Weil es schon was gibt, was Westerm heißt vielleicht?
Nee, oder?
das hat das hat er wieder raus gehauen
at new command or script
download western user bin startpunkt
sh open
ok das ist das ist freudig alter das ist
echt
global schicht not working
global art is running but shortcuts als setzend wieder und werk
wir sind aber wahrscheinlich die einzigen die damit probleme haben
How to fix this error. Okay, mal gucken was die KI sagt. Lull. Fix it by restarting the service.
Das kann aber doch eigentlich nicht sein.
Okay, da ist Suse.
Okay, geil, keine Antwort.
Dentke.
Plasma.
ok na dann wenn das die ki sagt dann muss das auch so sein
ok
at new aber jetzt application oder download western user bin open west ham hier
sechs minuten
Das ist schon ein Script, oder?
Okay, das hat keinen Bock.
Das hat keinen Bock.
User, bin.
Guck mal, open western hier, da gibt es schon ein Script.
Null.
Open western hier.
Where's the term not found?
Geil.
Nice.
Also das ist irgendwie broken, die Shortcut-Geschichte.
Ähm.
Das ist aber in der Tat ziemlich dumm.
Das ist aber...
Ähm.
Tja.
Äh.
Wie, wie, wie...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie wir das jetzt hinkriegen.
Ich würde ja schon gerne mein Terminal starten.
Das wäre schon sehr nice, wenn ich ein Terminal starten könnte.
Das hätte was.
Ach, guck mal, Recent Files.
Would you like to launch this file?
Launch execution files without asking.
Ja, klar.
Okay, das funzt.
Das funzt aber nur.
Das funzt aber nur, weil der Finder Magic macht.
Kann man jetzt einen Shortcut setzen?
Set Window Shortcut.
Ctrl Enter.
das ist aber ziemlich pp gare aber wirklich
an dem window shortcut ist was anderes
Aber das Pin
Pin to Task Manager
Okay
Jetzt ist es weg
Aber okay
Configure Icon Only Task
Kann ich das jetzt irgendwie starten dann?
Also das ist
Dumm
Das ist schon echt dumm
Activate widget as if clicked.
Kann ich da jetzt sagen hier?
Ne.
Ok Leute, vergesst es.
Also das funzt nicht richtig.
Das ist schon echt blöd.
Ne.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen,
scheiß drauf.
Ne, Shortcuts.
Shortcuts gehen nicht.
Kann keine Shortcuts.
Shortcuts einrichten.
Shortcuts not working.
Ist doch schon ein Skript.
Ah, das ist eine gute Idee.
Was?
The Component
Net Local Start Desktop
does not exist.
So, okay.
Jetzt Settings. Jetzt fügen wir das da mal
ein und dann mal gucken,
was er jetzt hier von sich gibt.
Shortcuts.
Zack.
Add. Command or
Script.
Downloads.
Western. User.
Bin. Start.
Add.
Hä?
Was ist das denn jetzt?
The fuck?
Chat.
Warum geht das jetzt?
Das macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich hab doch nicht...
Ich hab nicht mal irgendwas gemacht.
easy
das verstehe ich nicht
dass okay dass das das check ich nicht gut wie dem auch sei top funst alles gut nice
gg west herr ach so war mein reines würde ja noch gucken wie war wie konnte ich dem jetzt
sagen hier more actions no title bar and frame das muss ich jetzt über window rules machen sonst
sonst kommt es ja immer wieder ok settings so ruhe lutz at new window maus richtig aber
detect window properties
bam
ähm
window class
ok, window class match
western
no title
aha
ok, und wo sage ich
jetzt, dass er da kein
no title
No title by end frame.
Äh.
Yes.
Leute, guckt mal, das Anti-Aliasing ist komplett kaputt.
Seht ihr das?
Hier sind teilweise von diesem Button
sind Sachen nicht das Anti-Aliasing,
das Subpixel-Gedöns,
wie auch immer das heißt.
Da sind manche Pixel grün und...
Also das stimmt auf jeden Fall nicht.
Okay, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Apply now.
Hä?
Ich glaube, das ist ein Mesa-Bug aktuell.
Jawoll, nice.
wir können das ja mal ausprobieren indem wir jetzt hier settings aber
aufmachen schade dass es jetzt hier das settings sind
da kann man nämlich mal gucken jetzt sagen wir einfach mal sap pixel rendering namen
ein hinting namen und das machen wir aus so und jetzt gehen wir wieder auf rules
warum ist jetzt weg
Achso, ich hätte Apply drücken müssen.
Das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Deswegen ging das wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht.
Add Property.
No Title.
Okay, das funzt nicht.
Da bin ich zu doof für.
Okay, aber das ist immer noch.
Das ist immer noch.
Manche Icons sind grün und so als sind die Pixels nicht richtig.
Und wie kann ich das jetzt editieren?
Hast du Full RGB Range eingestellt?
Du meinst...
Display Configuration?
Du meinst hier?
Keep.
Wir können mal Limited einstellen.
Vielleicht ist das dann besser.
Window, Rule.
Ne, das ist immer noch.
Könnte am Capture liegen.
Ehrlich gesagt, wenn...
ähm,
die Capture Card
irgendwelche Pixel-Farbinformationen
falsch capturen würde,
dann würde das alles ganz anders
aussehen.
Wie gesagt, das liegt immer ein bisschen daran,
wie man schiebt, ja? Guckt hier.
Das liegt in welchem Pixel
das gerendert wird.
Deswegen ist meine Vermutung, dass das
irgendeine Subpixel-Rendering-Sache
von dem Front ist, ja?
Aber das müssen wir auch noch fixen.
Weil so, das sind so Dinger,
die die die die Träger mich richtig hart
aber jetzt will ich vor meint dass man West Ham
erst mal keine Titel mehr hat
also jetzt
Jetfunk geht es nicht
editier mal das West Ham Maxima ist stark nicht ab West Ham Maxima ist
starten noch überhaupt nicht da.
Title.
Äh.
Nee, das war was anderes.
Remember.
Remember. Ah, remember.
Das heißt, ich kann's jetzt.
I remember.
Nee.
Okay, so einfach ist es so.
Einfach ist es anscheinend.
Der checkt das nicht.
ok regular expression match
das juckt den überhaupt nicht
Das juckt den Null
Boss
Bam
まあまあまあ
まあ
Die Wendung wird sofort zur gewonnenen Anzahl gesetzt und wird später nicht beeinflusst.
Erinnerst du dich?
Die Anzahl der Wendung wird erinnern und jedes Mal, wenn die Wendung erst erstellt wird, wird die erinnern-Anzahl verringert.
also es juckt nicht hier
das interessiert ihn mal überhaupt nicht ob der kram
window type all window types ja das ist natürlich schon mal doof wenn solche sachen
wieder nicht funktionieren.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich hier Punkt Sternchen
eintrage?
Moment.
Moment. Wenn da Punkt Sternchen drinsteht,
sollte dann nicht eigentlich jetzt
alles hier verschwinden von jedem Fenster?
Einen Moment. Exact Match.
Regular Expression.
Äh.
Das macht gar nichts?
Weil KDE das Beste ist unter Wayland.
Okay, Chat, das funktioniert.
Das ist irgendwie nicht so geil.
Substream Match West Term.
Es trifft auch auf alle Windows zu.
Guck mal.
No title by frame force.
Das muss eigentlich...
Okay.
KDE.
No title.
Window rule does not work.
Näh, Sway ist für mich da
keine gute Alternative
Ich könnte auch Hyperland oder Mango
oder Niri oder so verwenden
Aber ganz im Ernst, ich hab den Eindruck
das Gesamtpaket ist bei KDE einfach am besten
Stell das mal
in deiner Westterm-Config ein
Pass mal auf
Da wär ich ja noch nicht drauf gekommen
Das funzt bei neueren Western-Versionen anscheinend nicht.
Wir können es übrigens mal so machen.
Oh ne, man muss das großschreiben.
Okay.
Also prinzipiell funktioniert das ja.
Weil guck hier, man kann hier sagen.
Aha, was ist das?
Configure special application setting.
da sieht man jetzt wie kacke das aussieht wenn ich habe ja das ganze zeug aus ausgeschaltet
hier guck mal ich habe hier alles ausgeschaltet sub pixel rendering anti aliasing
Und wenn ich das jetzt wieder einschalte
Dann sieht es wahrscheinlich besser aus
Guck, jetzt sieht es wieder besser aus
Okay, dann
Das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren
Ich stelle das mal wieder aus
Das aus
Dann sollte der Text richtig mies aussehen
Wenn ich das nochmal neu starte
aber dann können wir gucken ob dann das mit den icons richtig ist ich vermute nämlich dass sap
pixel rendering rgb probleme macht dass meine vermutung wegen den icons okay was könnte man
jetzt hier machen special applications settings special windows settings ok window type select
Moment, was ist denn das?
Moment, Window Rules?
Das habe ich doch hier schon.
Gibt es das jetzt nochmal?
Add Property.
Title.
No.
Force.
Das juckt ihn einfach nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich wette mit euch,
das sind irgendwelche Wailand-Bugs, in die man hier reinläuft
jetzt.
Also, Moment, yes.
Ah!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Schätke, Schätke.
Ah, es funzt, es funzt.
Ich, okay, ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt anders gemacht
hab, aber jetzt funktioniert's.
Exzellent, Leute.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Huge.
Huge. Easy.
Also ich würde sagen, es war extremely easy.
In Wirklichkeit
habe ich das natürlich schon lange
kapiert, wie es gehen muss.
Ich wollte das zwar IQ-Test für den Chat.
Easy as fuck.
Get rekt.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Richtig easy.
Mehr easy geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Okay, jetzt
reboote ich mal.
Chat, es geht...
Okay, Reboot funktioniert doch.
Schnell umstöpseln.
Ähm.
Ja.
Müssen wir gleich noch ein paar andere Sachen einstellen.
Ich hätte noch gerne CPU Auslastung. Kannst du dem angelegten Window Rule mal schauen. Ja, ja.
Ups, ich kacken. Jetzt habe ich das rausgezogen. Dabei muss ich doch jetzt hier mein Passwort
eingeben
ich hoffe mein fonds rendering sieht jetzt richtig schön hässlich aus
hoffe ich mal ein fonds rendering alter das sieht richtig räudig aus so muss
das sein und jetzt gucken wir mal gleich window
Rules, ob das jetzt immer noch so ist.
Window Rules.
Es ist immer noch so.
Fuck! Das ist nicht das Subpixel
Rendering.
Hier, guck mal. Das ist immer noch
grün zwischendurch.
Das ist ja Schrott. Gut, aber dann können wir
immerhin jetzt, dann können wir das
wieder schön machen, okay?
Feature kein Bug.
Das können wir wieder ein bisschen...
dass es nicht mehr ganz so hässlich aussieht, okay?
So, sieht schon wieder besser aus, ne?
Rule.
Also gucken wir jetzt mal in die Window-Rule rein,
was an der jetzt besser ist.
Exact Match.
Okay.
Yes, yes, force.
Leute, keine Ahnung, was da jetzt der Unterschied ist,
aber es funktioniert jetzt und vorher hat es nicht funktioniert.
Vielleicht war mein Regex verkehrt.
Das könnte am Encoder liegen, weil der Chroma Subsampling macht.
Das heißt, ich soll mal ein Passthrough auf dem Display machen und gucken, ob der Passthrough das auch hat.
Versuch mal Full HD 120 Hz.
Wieso? Ich habe Full HD 240 Hz. Das sollte doch keinen Unterschied machen.
ok wartet mal wegen hdmi wie jetzt um ein trend window ruhe
und dann haben die ums aus schreiber ok chat mache ich gleich gleich ich will jetzt mal kurz
hier was checken weil hier kann man ja auch noch ein paar sachen einstellen videoformat vielleicht
xrgb was ist da jetzt der unterschied aus irgendwelchen gründen ist xrgb gut nv 12 sagt
P-U-0-0
Das ist auch okay?
Das ist auch okay
Wobei ich ja da gar keinen Unterschied erkenne
Ähm
Chat das ist aber das kann aber eigentlich nicht daran liegen
Also es ist doch das liegt schon am format aber dann muss ich das hier auch umstellen
Kennt ihr chat gibt es irgendwie einen guten color test wo man sagen kann ob das
Wenn aus irgendwelchen gründen habe ich jetzt auf limited lag das daran ich kann
Seit warum habe ich das darauf
Warum habe ich das da auf Off-Limited stehen die ganze Zeit?
Keep.
Okay, jetzt ist alles gut.
Ich würde jetzt hier schauen.
Was ist, wenn ich jetzt hier auf Any gehe?
Jetzt ist es wieder grün, oder?
Ja.
Geil. Okay.
Das liegt aus irgendwelchen Gründen hier dran.
Und Chat, ich habe keinen Plan,
warum.
Color Space?
Äh, no.
Color Range?
Full?
Limited?
Ne, das juckt den überhaupt gar nicht.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen
zwischen
Full und Limited?
Kann mein Monitor das überhaupt anzeigen?
Kein Plan, ey.
So.
Also, also anscheinend ist es aber
das hier, was was bringt.
Video-Format
Yui 2.
Und alles ist gut, wenn Yui 2 eingestellt ist.
Ups.
Oh, das war jetzt natürlich etwas doof.
Und witzigerweise...
Bei dir hat sich was verändert, ja, ja.
If the color looks washed out.
Aber hier, das sieht so viel
washed out aus.
Aber ich finde, washed out sieht es
besser aus. Das ist das Schlimme.
Chat, ich finde, washed out sieht es besser aus.
Und woher weiß ich, was mein Monitor überhaupt unterstützt?
Sieht man das in den Windows-Settings irgendwie vielleicht?
Ne, in Windows-Settings sieht man doch prinzipiell nichts, oder?
windows settings ist doch der größte schritt überhaupt advanced display mit
depth 8 bit ok ist das jetzt das ist das ist limited oder ist 8 bit ist das
limited
ok rgb limited versus voll
und rgb sollte jeder morgen okay dann guckt dann gucke ich mal kurz nach ob das mein monitor
unterstützt sorry xl moment das ding heißt doch thank you ist das ja was für
ein monitor habe ich denn steht nichts dran oder steht da was dran irgendwo
Da steht irgendwo was dran.
Thank you.
Guck mal kurz bei Amazon.
Das habe ich nicht bei Amazon gekauft glaube ich.
Lass mich mal kurz checken.
Amazon.
Nein, habe ich nicht über Amazon bestellt.
Kann man sich nicht anzeigen lassen,
was man wirklich für einen Monitor hat.
unter Windows, das Ding muss sich doch irgendwie melden.
Ne.
Monitor, Generic Monitor.
Geil.
Windows, Alter. Keckel.
Thank you, sorry.
240 Hertz,
1080p Monitor.
Was habe ich denn für einen?
Ja, ich weiß doch nicht mal, wie meiner heißt.
So was, das...
Also, der sieht dem ähnlich.
So was in der Richtung, ja.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Warte mal, ich habe doch hier Knöpfe unten dran.
Picture Mode, Gaming 3.
Okay, whatever.
System.
Moment.
System?
information
XL 2546s
XL 2546s habe ich
RGB
Oder specification
Manual
ok top und nach was muss ich da jetzt gucken chat auflösung safety benutzer
handbuch ist aber gar nicht auf deutsch haben rgb
hdmi rgb pc range bestimmt den bereich der farbskalen da kann man das
einstellen.
Also, wie? Moment.
Wo muss ich? Alter, ich wusste gar nicht, dass
mein Monitor das kann.
Wo muss ich da hin?
Das ist meiner hier.
Das ist meiner.
Hier, 2x6. RGB-Bereich.
Wo war das jetzt nochmal?
Display. Okay, okay.
Display?
RGB Range.
Auto Detect.
Ja, geil.
Ähm.
Wie kann ein Monitor
das Auto detekten?
Okay.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, es ist 255.
Ziemlich sicher.
Wenn ich das umschalte dazwischen, dann...
Dann bleibt es gleich.
Also, ja.
Also ich denke mal 255.
Okay, also.
Automatic.
Lassen wir jetzt hier stehen.
Gut.
So, dann, Chat, dann rebooten wir nochmal, weil es richtig mies aussieht gerade.
Wir können übrigens, ah, ich hab noch eine Idee.
Haha, wartet mal.
Log in again immediately after log off.
Das machen wir jetzt einmal, weil ich will mein KDE einmal resetten, weil das sieht sonst so kacke aus.
Log out.
Log out now.
Jetzt lockt er mich direkt back in.
Nice. Guck.
Und jetzt sieht die Schrift auch nicht mehr ganz so mies aus.
Excellent.
Exquisite.
Sehr gut. Da sind wir wieder.
So. Gibt es sowas wie eine schöne CPU?
Aber wisst ihr, was ich immer noch komisch finde?
Yui 2 NV12 Elgato.
Da muss ich mal gucken, was der Unterschied ist.
Yui 2 bietet eine etwas verbesserte Farbleistung
Also, okay, aber es ist auf jeden Fall so
Dass
Yui 2
keine Probleme bei
der Icon-Anzeige hat.
Fast Fetch. Oh, das meint es.
Das Wichtigste. Das Wichtigste
muss noch drauf.
Okay.
By the way, da ist er.
Fast Fetch.
Ganz wichtig.
Ja, hast du schon recht.
Allerwichtigste.
Das sieht jetzt mehr oder weniger genauso...
Chat, die Farben sind exakt.
Guck doch mal.
Die Farben von hier und hier, die sind exakt gleich.
Zwischen der VM und dem hier.
Das ist wirklich gar kein Unterschied.
Also das passt.
Das ist gut so.
Passt Fetch.
Und Neo Fetch geht jetzt auch, weil das ein Alias bei mir ist.
So.
Mich stören so kleine Sachen.
Ja.
Und auch noch ganz wichtig.
Bibata.
Cursor.
Bibata Cursor.
Theme.
Was für ein Cursor Theme
hab ich hier nochmal?
Äh.
Maus Cursor.
Bibata Modern Amber.
Bibata.
Da ist es bestimmt dabei, oder?
Wenn ich jetzt Bibata Cursor Theme installiere.
Leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz pinkeln, während es installiert.
Yes.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Da bin ich wieder.
Yes.
Äh, was zum...
Moment.
kompiliert der mir aus irgendwelche Cursor oder was?
Hast du 240 Hertz auf einer VM?
Nein.
Ich habe einen Mini-PC.
Guck mal.
Ein Mini-PC.
Und zwar einen.
Steht das hier irgendwo?
Ja.
Mit AMD Ryzen.
7840 HS.
Richtiger HS hier der Prozessor.
So, und mit 780M Graphics.
Das flutscht.
Wieso Wayland Probleme in der VM macht?
Weil viele Anwendungen einfach nicht laufen.
KDE läuft tatsächlich in der VM auch noch am besten.
Also Performance ist kacke.
Und viele Anwendungen starten nicht.
Unter Nicht-KDE.
Das ist die letzten 2-3 Jahre besser geworden, aber gut ist das immer noch nicht.
Und ich glaube halt, dass X immer weiter ausgefacet wird.
Deswegen jetzt halt die Kiste.
Hier, Cursors.
Da haben wir Bibata.
Was hatte ich?
Bibata, Mordor und Ember, ne?
Exzellent.
24?
40.
Bam.
Huge.
Maus-Tiger.
24.
28.
sehr schön sehr gut ok als nächstes jet brains toolbox
wo kommt das ist das eigentlich offiziell von denen oder vom fress war
so und ich hätte gerne auch eine art was ist denn das da oben
und schaue gern ich weiß nicht was es wird einfach ausgeblendet
es soll was ich jetzt noch gerne hätte so ein bisschen cpu auslastung gibt es da gibt es auch
bestimmt irgendwelche Widgets
für
irgendwelche Widgets.
Peak at Desktop. Das will ich eigentlich
nicht haben. Wie kriege ich denn
das denn weg?
Show Panel Configuration.
Äh.
Irgendjemanden planen, wie man dieses Icon
hier wegkriegt?
Wie kriege ich das hier weg?
Add or manage widgets?
Ah!
Aber ich kann es immer noch nicht ausblenden.
Was? All widgets running.
System tray?
peak desktop ach hier und jetzt remove all instances das ist aber umständlich
alter okay gibt es hier sowas wie cpu und all widgets individual core usage das ist gut
Moment
Ich will hier oben was einblenden
Ne
Ich will kein Widget auf dem Desktop
Ich will hier oben was einblenden
Auf die Taskleiste ziehen
Also so oder was
Ah!
Und wie kann ich es jetzt verschieben?
Was habe ich...
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
CPU?
Jetzt ist es wieder weg.
Okay, exit. Da ist es perfekt. Da soll es hin. Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Ja, oh, das ist doch nice, oder?
Das ist fast so ein bisschen, guck mal, das ist ein bisschen wie das, was ich in meiner VM habe. In meiner VM habe ich hier oben auch sowas.
Das gefällt mir, das ist nice. NVTop, was macht meine Grafikkarte? Dinger?
Okay, das gefällt mir jetzt langsam schon ganz gut.
Ja, Winnie, mich verwirrt es auch.
So, das ist doch jetzt schon mal echt ganz nice.
Dann gehen wir mal hier. Jetbrain. Jetbrains.
Ach so, kann man hier jetzt auch mit Emojis und so.
Ah.
Okay, das ist in der Tat ganz gut. Ja.
Ich kriege.
Okay, Jetbrains Produkte.
Was brauchen wir da?
Wir brauchen
Rust Rover,
IntelliJ,
Goland,
Pycharm,
Sea Lion,
Rider,
Gateway,
Jetvo ist Goland.
Habe ich das schon? Ja.
Gucken wir mal kurz.
Ah, jetzt geht's wieder.
Ich wusste wie...
Chat, wusstet ihr,
dass es free-h gibt?
Die f-h schon immer,
aber free-h...
Ich hab mich so auf minus m eingeschossen.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
ganz ehrlich ich habe jetzt hier west firma finde natürlich nicht west haben
habe ich jetzt ja hier über so ein skript drin
wer ist nicht sinnvoll ich installiere das doch über sauer mit dem nightly bin
wobei ganz ehrlich jedes ich will eigentlich gar kein nightly haben dann
geht es morgen wieder nicht richtig mein terminal ich habe jetzt ein stand der
ist okay ich abdate ist einfach von hand ab und zu mal
mal gucken wie er ausgelastet ist wie kein h top wichtigste wichtigste tool hier
stopp
aber schon kraft in so einem kleinen pizzeria
sieht schon krass aus wenn man hier 16 kerne oben sieht warum sie nicht einfach
aller kritik weil western beste ist
b top mag ich nicht hart ob beste
Schön, dass so viele von euch am Start sind heute.
Was findest du besser an Westerm?
Okay, ich gebe zu, das ist keine gute Begründung jetzt.
Ich weiß es nämlich nicht mehr im Detail, aber ich habe das vor 2-3 Jahren oder wie lange ich auch immer das schon verwende,
war alles verglichen, a la Kitty, Kitty, Westerm.
Und da war Westerm das, was nahezu alles hatte, was ich wollte.
Und seitdem habe ich das.
Der Bot hat sich jetzt übrigens gemeldet. Welcher Bot?
lua config ja nur config ist auch mega nice für western das ist richtig bock da kann man zum
beispiel guck dir mal das ist das klingt erst mal bescheuert eine volle programmier sprache zu haben
in der im terminal aber da kann man solche sachen machen ja hier guck wenn man rechte
wenn man rechte maustaste ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr was da programmiert habe was down
Downstreak ein button mittel
Achso ja dass man ordentlich copy pasten kann und wenn nichts selektiert ist also zum beispiel was ich selbst gebaut hat mit der lua config ist
wenn ich
Rechts also hier wenn ich jetzt rechts clique wenn was selektiert ist und ich klicke rechts
Dann geht das in die zwischenablage
Ist nicht selektiert und ich klicke rechts wird das gepastet
Das abartigste an Lua ist das Erase bei 1 anfangen
Äh
Das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen
Chat
Steuerung W funktioniert nicht
Warum funktioniert Steuerung W nicht
Das ist ein Bug
Chatge, ich habe einen Bug gefunden
Wenn Punkt Slash am Anfang steht
Punkt, Punkt, ne Moment, Steuerung W
Ist das, ist das schon immer so gewesen?
Ne, ist es nicht, guck
Hier kann ich mit Steuerung W, in der alten Version kann ich mit Steuerung W
Ähm, auch Punkt Slash löschen
Ich glaub das ist, das
Also, ich würde fast drauf tippen
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, sowas müsste eigentlich an der Shell liegen
und nicht am
Terminal.
Das ist intended?
Aber warum ist es dann bei mir
mit der gleichen Config auf der
VM nicht?
Guck mal, solche Zeichen kann man hier gar nicht mal löschen, wenn die vorne stehen.
Wenn du nur Punkt Slash hast, wird es gelöscht?
Ne, ne, guck, ich habe nur Punkt Slash, da wird nichts gelöscht.
Guck.
Special Characters
Add Start
Ctrl W
Ist das vielleicht
Okay wir testen mal ob das ein Z eine ZSH Geschichte ist
Es ist eine ZSH Geschichte
Ich hab irgendeine Z
Version
5.9.
Okay, was habe ich hier?
ZSH minus Version.
5.9.
Okay, Chat, ich schiebe es
auf Wayland.
Im Zweifelsfall kann man das alles auf Wayland schieben.
Nee, nee, das kommt...
Wie gesagt, in meiner Vorhabe, ich habe die gleiche ZSH-Version
und die gleiche
ähm, ZSH-
Config, ja.
Sehr weird, Champ.
Ähm, das kann ich übrigens auch löschen hier.
Okay, wir fragen mal die KI.
Die weiß das.
Wenn ich, äh,
Wenn ich in meiner Zisch eine Zeile mit Punkt Slash oder Minus starte und dann Ctrl plus W für Delete Word Backwards drücke, wird nichts gelöscht.
Früher war das nicht so.
Okay, das labert dummes Zeug.
Das ist ein laber dummes Zeug.
Echoworld Chars.
Classic.
Siehst du?
Ja.
Naja.
Das ist es nicht.
Okay, ich hab legit kein Plastenschirm
Okay, wisst ihr was wir jetzt ausprobieren?
Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus
Mit dem alten Westterm, okay
Das sowas sollte eigentlich nicht
Am Terminal liegen
Es liegt am Terminal
Das ist ein Bug
Wie kann denn sowas an einem Terminal liegen?
Hä?
Das macht ja gar
The fuck?
Das macht ja gar keinen Sinn
Das macht doch gar keinen Sinn
Das kriegt die Shell
Und die macht dann was
Weil vor allem in Bash
What
Control W macht das Terminal doch gar nichts
Macht das irgendwas
Control
Eventuell ist es West Termin
Wayland West
Das macht doch gar keinen Sinn
Das sollte das Termin
doch gar nicht interessieren
Okay, probieren wir mal was
Ich hab ne Idee
Wie ging das nochmal?
Westterm disable Wayland
Enable Wayland
Hier
Da unten müssen wir hin
Enable Wayland gleich true
Oder?
Das sollte jetzt hier die default sein.
Okay, so.
Enable Wayland Falls.
Ne, ne, ne, das ist es nicht.
Dafür laggt es as fuck.
Mit x an.
Also das ist es nicht.
Das ist ein Bug.
Das ist ein Bug in Westterm.
Aber was auch immer für einer, Alter.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt die Auswahl...
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt die Auswahl zwischen einem kaputten Cursor...
...ruckelt im Resize...
...oder in ZSH nicht löschendes...
Das Jahr des Linux Desktop Star, ja.
Ja, dann habe ich echt keine Ahnung mehr, was...
Ja, das ist aber echt ziemlich, ziemlich dumm.
Muss man jetzt mal so sagen.
Okay, dann halt...
halt okay ich weiß was wir machen das mit dem cursor sollten sich eigentlich
nach einem reboot fixen wir den macht nicht ich weiß ich weiß was wir machen
wir schalten jetzt weiland aus und ich weiß den kram einfach nicht easy outplayed
Shortcuts.
Der Steuerung W wird ja daran übergeben.
Wo ist denn hier mein Start?
Okay, machen wir es mal hier.
Add Application.
West Term.
Add.
Control Enter.
Yes.
Gut.
So, es ist jetzt eklig beim Resizen,
aber das macht ja nichts,
weil ich das Ding eh mal im Fullscreen
hab.
Sonst kann ich... Moment, Moment,
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was zum...
Das geht immer noch nicht. Warte mal.
Wie jetzt?
Eben ging's doch.
Hä?
Chat, jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch.
Jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch.
Es hat doch eben einmal funktioniert.
Oder mehrfach, weiß ich nicht.
Moment, das funktioniert in beiden West-Terms.
Aber nur manchmal.
Hä?
Das Funst...
Moment.
Wenn ich das aus dem Terminal starte,
dann geht es.
Wenn ich das über die GUI starte,
dann geht es nicht.
Was will er mir denn jetzt hier sagen?
Wait a minute.
Da ist doch irgendwas ganz verkehrt.
Was ist das denn für Zeug?
okay geil jetzt jetzt jetzt geht's
installiere mal die night über hallo
Kann man das wieder löschen hier vielleicht?
Jetzt startet es gar nicht mehr.
Alter, ist das ein Abfuck, Mann.
Jetzt greift es gar nicht mehr.
Geil.
Top.
Null.
So, guck mal, jetzt ist es nicht so
Und wenn ich das hier drüber starte
Einfach so
Dann geht es mit dem Löschen auch nicht mehr
What the fuck, was ist das denn
Leute, ich schieb das auf Wayland
Das ist irgendeine Wayland-Geschichte
Weil mal geht's, mal geht's nicht
Ich schieb das
Das ist irgendeine Wayland-Sache
Sagt's euch
Okay, wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen?
Session, Lockout
Versuch mal ein anderes Terminal
Ja, okay, kann ich machen, aber da wird das wahrscheinlich funktionieren
Ganz, ganz weird
Äh, Moment, Moment
Warum speichert der, was zum
Alter, warum speichert der
Irgendwelche Sessions, der soll keine Sessions
Speichern
Session
Session, kann man das ausschalten?
Desktop Session
Session Restore
Start with empty session, genau
Okay, jetzt kann ich es aus irgendwelchen Gründen
gar nicht mehr starten
Ne, das funktioniert nicht
Sollen wir mal
Allerkriti? Das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Ne, das funktioniert auch nicht.
Das funktioniert auch nicht.
Dann ist es irgendeine...
Hä?
Das ist jetzt ganz
wie...
Irgendwas mit Steuerung W ist kaputt
hier unter Wayland. Ich schiebe das
einfach mal auf Wayland.
Schauen wir mal.
Shortcut.
Aber vorher geht es ja.
Das ist ja das Problem.
Guck mal.
Hier funktioniert es mit dem
STRG-W.
Hier funktioniert es nicht mit dem STRG-W.
Es löscht einfach den letzten
Abschnitt nicht.
Wenn da vorne irgendein Sonderzeichen ist.
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Äh, das ist irgendwie jetzt weg.
Add.
Application.
Pass auf.
Oh, nee.
Jetzt backt er wieder rum.
User, bin, start
Okay, ne, geht aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Und, okay, das Funds da auch wieder
Aber, aber hier, guck mal
Das starten tut nicht
Zeit für reinstall
Ne
Reinstall das jetzt nicht
Aber komischerweise, manchmal
Funktioniert das ja
Guck, jetzt funktioniert es wieder
In dem alten Western funktioniert es
Moment, Moment
Konsole? Funktioniert es mit Konsole?
Konsole funktioniert jetzt auch nicht
Wenn ich Konsole über Konsole starte
Funktioniert es dann? Dann funktioniert es
What the fuck, Alter
Guck, starte ich das
aus dem Terminal raus, funktioniert's
Muss man das
Ey Leute, ich wette mit euch, das ist irgendein
Wailand-Shit
Ich könnte wetten
Alter.
Das wurde gestartet mit
Westerm Gui.
Aber wenn ich hier mein...
Guck mal, selbst wenn ich mein Start-Skript
ausführe, geht das.
Okay, nice.
Oder auch nicht nice.
Äh, sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Da geht's, tja.
Ja, guck mal, bei mir funktioniert's ja auch zum größten Teil.
Außer jetzt irgendwie...
Also, ganz...
Super...
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob das schon irgendwie gebeindet ist.
Control.
Alter, jetzt crasht das wieder.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
X11 mit I3 ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Vielleicht ist es ein Plasma-Bug, ja?
Control.
T.
Control plus W.
Soll ich das mal wegschmeißen?
Ne, macht keinen Unterschied
Das macht keinen Unterschied
Okay, jetzt habe ich
Pass mal auf
Biggest brain time
Ne, neu einloggen, das brauchen wir dafür wahrscheinlich nicht
Pass mal auf.
Biggest brain time.
Also wenn man das jetzt hier startet.
Ah, jetzt geht es auch wieder nicht.
Moment.
Das geht nicht.
So lange ist hier drin.
Guck mal.
Always new process, machen wir jetzt.
Always new process.
Gui, muss ich starten.
Westrom, Gui.
Ups.
Äh, was?
Äh.
Ah, jetzt wird es wieder gelöscht.
Okay.
Ah, Moment, Moment.
Download.
Western starts always new process.
Okay, dann geht es.
So, pass mal auf.
Biggest brain time.
Das erste, was wir jetzt nochmal ausprobieren, ist...
ich editiere hier mal mein Start-Skript
und sag dem
always
start always new process, okay?
Geht nett, hat nichts gebracht.
Also, jetzt habe ich noch eine Idee.
Also, pass mal auf, Westterm.
Man kann Westterm noch sagen,
es soll
genau und dann sagen wir jetzt okay west was man auf die sagen jetzt west start always new process
western start
Always new process
Wir starten jetzt das
Wir starten jetzt das Terminal um das Terminal zu starten
Okay
Okay das funktioniert zumindest schon mal
Das Ding da im Hintergrund ist ein bisschen dumm
Aber mal gucken
Fuck es funzt nicht
Es funzt nur, wenn ich das interaktiv starte.
Okay, das ist super random weird champ bug.
Das ist wirklich merkwürdig.
Das ist, das ist in der Tat
Deswegen, irgendwie
Ich kann's euch nicht genau sagen
Mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, das ist irgendeine Wayland-Kacke wieder
Ich bin auf Plasma
Wenn 6.6 das Neueste ist, ja
Arch, by the way
lul
ok
wir googeln jetzt
wir googeln da jetzt mal
ctrl plus w
was
ctrl plus w not working
nee nee nee
das muss irgendwas sein
innerhalb vom letzten Jahr
tmux
Wayland
Conflicting Shortcuts haben wir nicht
Control
In anderen...
Es spricht in der Tat
ein wenig für
globale Shortcuts,
weil es ist in anderen
Terminals auch so.
Ja, es ist in anderen...
Ist das auch so, aber...
Kannst du die Shortcuts resetten?
Ja, aber warum?
Ja, das ist auch schon so.
Ne, ne, das bringt ja nichts.
Das tut ja nicht.
Unter Wayland besonders kann das Input Framework IBUS Shortcuts blockieren.
Lösungen versuchen sie IBUS Setup zu starten und unter Shortscanner zu...
Moment was? Was zum Teufel ist IBUS Setup? Gibt's nicht. Blödsinn.
AI zieht sich da Dinger aus dem Poppes, Alter.
check current binding backwards what kill ja
das ist auch geil guck mal guck mal
Ja, wie jetzt?
Es ist normal, dass ich nichts sehe,
aber ich soll mich wundern, wenn ich nichts sehe.
Nee, Free Tier hat man, glaube ich,
zehn Nachrichten mit dem neuesten frei.
Ja, das erklärt das nicht.
Ja, meiner Meinung nach,
meiner Meinung nach,
kann das eigentlich.
kein Wayland-Problem sein.
So rational betrachtet.
Weil hier kommt das ja da an.
Aber mein Bauchgefühl
sagt, es ist irgendein Wayland-Shit.
Was halt auch merkwürdig ist,
ist, wenn ich hier drüber
starte,
dann funktioniert das.
Ja?
Okay.
Pass mal auf.
Six Head Time.
High IQ.
T-Mux execute
default command.
T-Mux minus C.
T-Mux minus C, sleep 1.
Ne, äh.
Doch, geht doch.
Okay, Funs.
So.
Western.
Okay, Funst.
Bim, Start.
Äh, öh, öh.
T-Mux minus C, Westterm.
Funst nicht.
Scheiße.
Bash geht, Bash geht.
Hab ich schon ausprobiert.
Bash geht.
Ich werde gleich mal meine ZSHRC löschen
und gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Oder nicht funktioniert.
Vielleicht setze ich da ja irgendwas,
was das kaputt macht.
Okay, das funzt nicht.
Ich muss das hier, glaube ich,
quoten.
Okay.
Achso, Westterm Start ist es, ne?
Westterm Start.
Kunst nicht.
Okay.
Enf.
Kunst nicht.
Probier mal Autoload, UZ, Select, Wordstyle, Selectstyle, Bash.
Ich weiß nicht.
Will ich eigentlich nicht.
Den Bash-Style.
Das ist ja aber sehr, sehr
merkwürdig.
Okay. Dann machen wir jetzt
was anderes.
MV ZSHRC
Blub.
Okay, Chat, das liegt an meiner, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, an meiner Zedders HRC.
Tommy schreibt, ich war jetzt auch in einigen Argumenten gefangen, was gegen IoT-Geräte spricht.
Ich wollte einfach nur meine Waschmaschine benutzen und musste erst warten, bis das Update abgeschlossen war.
Ich musste letztens meine Fahrradpedale-Firmware updaten.
Ich verstehe, dass Updates gemacht werden müssen, aber wieso macht man das nicht im 3er Nachts?
Weil die Hersteller alle irgendwie unfähig sind.
Ich habe letztens meine Fahrradpedale geupdatet.
Okay, Leute, es liegt an meiner ZSHRC
So viel ist schon mal sicher
Dann würde ich jetzt mal vorschlagen
Vielleicht liegt es an Starship
Wartet mal, vielleicht liegt es an Starship
Ne, es liegt nicht an Starship
Okay, wir machen es uns jetzt ganz einfach, Leute
So
Geht immer noch nicht
Wir tasten uns jetzt ran, was es ist
Hier, diese Dinger sind so...
Hier, hier, da ist doch irgendwas kaputt.
Hier drinnen.
Bind Key.
Bei diesem Bind Key Krempel ist irgendwas im Arsch.
Ich sag's euch.
Geht immer noch nicht?
Okay, passt mal auf.
Ich kommentiere jetzt dieses Bind Key Zeug aus.
Und dann geht's.
Nö.
Was?
Ich stelle Detektivsarbeit, ja.
Geht immer noch nicht?
Okay, äh.
Select Word Style Bash?
Ist es das hier?
Das ist es!
Select Word Style.
Select Word Style Bash.
Wie?
Kann ich mehr Undo?
Habe ich nicht meine Wimmerzähne
nicht drinnen stehen, dass ich ein Undo
Directory hab? Dass er sich das speichert?
Was das macht? Puh, kein Schimmer.
Das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich hab das irgendwann mal gesetzt.
Äh, Undo Directory.
Ach, .wim gibt es nicht.
Okay.
So, also
das ist anscheinend das Problem.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Es kann mir immer noch keiner erklären,
wenn realistisch betrachtet,
warum
ich ein neues Terminal starte und dann geht's
und so geht's
nicht, oder? Das macht überhaupt
keinen Sinn.
Kann sich da irgendeiner einen Reim drauf machen?
What's
that?
10 Minuten
muss ich weg, Leute.
Die große Preisfrage ist, warum funktioniert es dann bei mir auf der VM, ne?
Das muss man alles nicht verstehen.
Aber das ist das Problem, so wie es ausschaut.
Ah, hier, zack.
Äh, Moment, so, jetzt.
Das ist das Problem.
Zusammenfassen war easy.
Alles, immer Eats.
Alles standardmäßig.
immer, egal wie,
das ist ungefähr so,
wie in jedem Competitive
PvP-Game, wenn man gewinnt,
ist es GG Eats.
Wenn man verliert,
ist das ganz, dann muss man
sich einfallen lassen, warum man verloren hat.
Und das lag nicht daran, dass man schlecht gespielt hat,
sondern an den Teammates, die scheiße waren,
irgendwelche OP-Sachen, die die anderen
benutzt haben.
Braindead Teammates.
Wenn man verliert ist es GGWP, ne.
Wenn man verliert ist Ragequit.
GGWP, GGWP Eats oder so.
Das ist nur wenn man gewinnt.
Und wenn man gewinnt, dann loben die Leute auch gerne die Teammates.
Oh nice, Teammates, very well played.
Und nächstes Mal kriegt ihr den gleichen Typ im Gegnerteam.
Und dann wird geflamed.
aber jetzt mal im ernst das ding sieht doch jetzt schon halbwegs benutzbar aus oder muss
man doch echt mal sagen damit kommt man doch schon klar habe ich noch eine wichtige config
vergessen die geht repost brauchen wir auf jeden fall noch aber noch habe ich noch irgendwelche
das mal kurz hier gucken na geil gibt es irgendwelche wichtigen config falls askig
war ja ja ja exzellente ex das ist richtig richtig an die pdp background leute
dazu keine autos und suggestions was meinst du jetzt das hier da hinten das oder wie browser
profile habe ich noch nicht was die quarry um das ist das ist in der tat enorm wichtig
wüsste ich gar nicht wie das ohne funktionieren soll
exquisite ja so ist das schön ein bisschen beschleunigen das ganze hier
wollen wir das nicht als rust fork nehmen hatten wir nicht letzten sind
ascii aquarium in go was das richtig verpixelt und eklig außer nie b top mag
ich nicht. Wie oft... Die Leute kommen immer mit
B-Top. Nee, nee, nee. B-Top ist nix.
H-Top
beste. Okay, Chat.
Ultimative, ultimative
Frage an euch.
Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar letzten schon mal gefragt.
Ähm...
Ach so.
Ey. Wie mache ich denn das
jetzt? Ah. Guck mal da.
KDE.
Hier. H-Top versus
B-Top.
B-Top. Setzt mal. Allein schon ist das
nicht richtig funktioniert.
Guck mal hier.
B-Top
versus H-Top.
Chat.
Eins müssen wir
noch machen.
Oh, fuck. Was zum... Ah, ich weiß nicht mal,
was ich jetzt gemacht habe. Oh, fuck.
Chat. Ich habe irgendwas...
Okay. Menü. Wir müssen noch...
Wenn ich das hier schon sehe, kriege ich Anfälle.
Äh.
Beam.
Das da müssen wir machen, dass das ordentlich aussieht.
Okay.
H-Top versus B-Top.
Ich sag euch ganz ehrlich,
H-Top beste.
B-Top ist so krass überladen.
Ich glaube, wir haben
sogar letztens schon mal eine Umfrage gemacht.
Aber können wir auch machen.
Eine Umfrage.
Ich glaube keins davon ist written in Rust.
So, Umfrage ist gestartet.
Soll ich nicht mal nach Rast suchen?
Okay, ich muss da weg, Chat.
Aber ist doch gut eingerichtet hier.
Geil, jetzt wird er
bottom.
Yet another cross-platform graphic process
system monitor. Alter, das hat
12,9
K Sterne.
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Also 50-50.
Habt ihr wieder gut gemacht, Chat.
Habt ihr wieder gut gemacht.
Hartop beste einer da ist einer nur ist nicht das ist nicht so kein klarer Gewinner.
Graphical Process Monitor.
Okay, zeig mal jetzt kommt hier Ritten in Rust noch Alternative.
Gucken was bottom.
habe ich etwas falsch gemacht
gott
da muss erst mal drauf kommen
Ich war's
Der Hardtop ist einfach beste
Machen wir ein bisschen Auslastung
Und gucken uns das Ganze an
Ich finde diese Grafen hier
Ist total überflüssig, braucht kein Mensch
Memory Grafen
Braucht auch kein Mensch
network also das einzig wirklich gute bei diesen tools finde ich die netzwerk anzeige
patrick richtige alpha giga chat sigma des die lesen direkt aus brock aus die
benutzen überhaupt keine programme dafür box that wird da ausgelesen
äh
Storage kann H-Top auch
guck
mittlerweile
das ist auch praktisch
also Netzwerk
wenn H-Top noch Netzwerk hätte wäre nice
ja gebe ich zu
Ich möchte das abbrechen.
Aber das Zeug, das braucht keiner.
Wirklich keiner.
Nee.
Jet.
Weg.
Hardtop.
Es bleibt bei Hardtop.
H-Top-Beste.
So, eine Sache
will ich mir jetzt noch mal kurz angucken.
Wenn ich Free
aufmache und mal
hier Go-Land starte
und Rider starte,
wie viel ist dann am Ende noch
von meinem Memory
noch da?
Don't send.
Und ich habe noch keine Projekte geladen, wohlgemerkt.
Visual Studio.
Ach komm, Rider.
Nix.
E-Map Visual Studio.
JetBrains IDE.
Without Plugins.
Goland Ghost AI, wenn ich sowas schon lese.
werden.
Okay, brauchen gar nicht so viel gerade.
Wahrscheinlich, weil noch keine Projekte geladen sind.
Okay.
Aber kommt man gut mit klar.
Muss man sagen, kommt man gut mit
klar.
Wir müssen mal, ich muss mal kurz, eine Sache
will ich jetzt noch checken.
Wie warm das Ding wird
mit CPU-Auslastung.
Das müssen wir gerade mal kurz ausprobieren.
Sensors.
Was ist denn hier von
meine...
Das ist meine CPU, oder?
TCTL.
Ja, das ist meine CPU, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Und jetzt machen wir mal hier S.
Tui. Stress.
So, jetzt werden alle CPU-Kerne ausge...
Die Temperatur direkt hier.
Die Rakete startet.
Es rauscht gar nicht so sehr.
Der dreht ein bisschen hoch, aber hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Hohohohoho.
Jetzt hat der Lüfter ein bisschen hochgedreht.
Was ist denn
Warning Temperature
bei AMD?
100?
105?
90?
Weiß das jemand?
Naja, aber das geht klar.
Guck mal, für so ein Mini-PC mit so viel...
Ähm...
Mit so wenig Platz
ist das doch vollkommen
fein.
Bleibt auch im Rahmen.
Okay, wenn der 85 darf,
ist das noch alles okay.
Guck mal, der wird sogar ein bisschen kühler jetzt,
nachdem der Lüfter richtig hochgedreht ist.
und der lüfter geht gerade richtig ab leute das ist ein reisen 7870 hs reisen
7840 hs das ist echt unglückliche bezeichnung oder glaube ich letztens
irgend ein newsartikel bei der bild gelesen habe da hieß einer huso b
Irgendeiner, der seit 23 Jahren für 8 Kinder Geld kassiert.
Und der hat einen Vornamen Huso gehabt.
Fand ich auch witzig, dass man so heißen kann, Alter.
Guck mal, geht vollkommen in Ordnung.
Vollkommen passt das hier mit der Temperatur.
Guck mal, die geht sogar jetzt runter.
Okay, excellent.
Chatge, Power off.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Ich muss jetzt mal ganz schnell noch was einkaufen.
Wem es gefallen hat, würde mich über ein Follow freuen.
Und wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Bis dann.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
See you.